good morning everyone welcome to
legislative
Administration um there is a new policy
on
signin um the signin sheet will stop
accepting new entries for those who wish
to speak at 8:
am the day of the hearing today if you
sign in after that time the committee
will not have your name before them
however I will provide an opportunity
for you to speak after all the
registered names are
called at that time you would raise your
hand
electronically sign in sheet will close
for purposes of registering your opinion
at
11:59 this
evening and moving on um as chair of the
House Legislative Administration
committee I find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of Co
pandemic and in accordance with house
rule 67 and the governor's emergency
order number 12 pursuing to executive
order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically this is a public hearing
on bills referred to the committee and
scheduled in the house calendar for
today an executive session may be held
on any Bill referred to the
committee please note that there is no
physical location for members of the
public to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this this
meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone all necessary information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court
website the notice for this meeting
complies with house rules in RSA
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call area code 603
3600 or email
HCS ledge. state.
n. in the event that the public is
unable to access the meeting the meeting
will be adjourned and
rescheduled please note that all votes
that are taken during this meeting shall
be done by roll call vote let's start
the meeting by taking a roll call
attendance when each member states their
presence please also State whether they
there is anyone in the room with you
during this meeting which is required
under the right to no
law power Ro representative ESP
speedia here and there is um the only
one in the
room representative
Frost hold on I am present remotely um
my office space is in a common space my
and my family is
home representative green here in the
room representative Hill here in the
legislative Administration committee
room representative
leay representative
mckenny
here at home
alone representative nutting
Wong I'm here but my father's learning
how to open up doors so I'm alone right
now but can't guarantee anything
later representative
Osborne representative
Packard representative
Richards I am here I'm remote um in my
office and there could be the occasional
question but my door is
closed representative rard I'm here I am
remote and I am
alone the clerk is here in the
L representative Simon here I'm in the
committee
room representative
Smith hi I'm here attending from my home
office in Manchester and I am
alone representative
wall thank you so we have a full day of
hearings today um the calendar listings
of the hearing is a little misleading
and I'd like to clarify that for the
members of the public watching or
listening on Zoom by
telephone um the plan is to listen to
the introduction of each of the bills at
the time stated in the calendar uh the
first bill
hcr2 uh the sponsors and
co-sponsors um will speak first and then
um members of the public uh and other
sponsors or other State Rep would be
listed in on our sheet after at the end
of going through all of these people we
will then call on anyone that uh puts up
their hand on on electronic zo or
indicates it on the
telephone the meetings from 11 o'clock
to 12 o'clock are uh each bill is uh
designated on the in the calendar with a
15 minute segment um beginning uh each
one of those bills will have 15 minutes
to be introduced by the sponsors or
co-sponsors at the end of those 15
minutes that hearing will be continued
until after lunch at 1
o'clock um at that time members of the
public and the members that have already
signed up um will be allowed to speak on
any of the bills that are occuring at at
1:00 um I will between each of those
bills um give the same announcement so
that everyone knows um there is an
opportunity for the the public to voice
their opinion beginning at one o' on any
of those
bills and that's about all I have um
with that I am ready to open the hearing
on House Bill uh
hcr2 and is the prime sponsor for
yes hello can you hear me uh
representative L yes we can hear you
fine welcome to house legisl uh yeah
legislative Administration um your the
floor is
yours thank you Mr chairman thank you me
members of the committee to quot James
Madison from Federalist Paper number 84
an elective disposition was not the
government we f for but one in which the
powers of government should be so
divided and balanced among the several
bodies of magistracy as that no one
could transcend their legal limits
without being effectually checked and
restrained by the others to further
quote James nadison the accumulation of
all powers legislative executive and
Judiciary in the same hands whether of
one a few or many and whether
hereditarily self-appointed or elective
may be justly pronounced the very
definition of tyranny AR a 440 5 was
never intended to dive the citizens of
this state into a prolonged and definite
state of emergency nor was it intended
to hand the executive branch unlimited
Authority with the ability to suspend
statute the Constitution and civil
liberties but unfortunately while that
was not the spirit of the law the result
in this current state of emergency has
been just that unlimited Authority
delivered to the executive branch with
no oversight quote promise pay a
constitution defines and limits the
powers of the government it creates it
therefore follows as a natural and also
a logical result that the governmental
exercise of any power not authorized by
the Constitution is an assumed power and
therefore illegal part one article 29 of
the New Hampshire state constitution
says the powers of suspending the laws
or the execution of them ought never to
be exercised but by the legislature or
by Authority derived there from to be
exercised in such particular cases only
as the legislature May expressly provide
for RSA 445 does not expressly provide
the executive branch with the ability to
suspend statute but in this state of
emergency it has been an assumed power
part one article 37 of the New Hampshire
state constitution reads in the
government of this state the three
essential Powers thereof to it the
legislative executive and judicial ought
to be kept as separate from and
independent of each other as the nature
of a free government will admit now I
fully understand that in times of Crisis
a bending of the rules must be made to
allow for concise and Swift action but
the necessity for such timely decisions
that could be made by The Stroke of a
pen has long since passed the handling
of the covid-19 crisis can and should be
made through a constitutionally
appropriate process that includes 425
Minds working together not just one as
legislators it is our duty and our right
to uphold our constitutional oath and
restore and protect the constitution of
the
state RSA 4452 C States the legislature
May terminate state of emergency by
concurrent resolution adopted by a
majority vote of each chamber the
governor's power to renew a declaration
of state of emergency shall terminate
upon the adoption of a concurrent
resolution under this
subparagraph the immediate crisis that
precipitated this emergency was that the
projected hospitalization rate of
covid-19 would outstrip Resources by the
beginning of Summer of 2020 our
hospitals were better equipped it became
evident that we would not exceed
Hospital capacity so much that we chose
to shut down our surge Flex facilities
indeed we have never ex exceeded 75% of
the total impatient bed capacity in New
Hampshire and the percentage of those
with covid-19 peaked at
11.6% while covid-19 continues to spread
the reality is there is no longer a
crisis that prevents the legislature
from working nor is there a crisis that
requires immediate actions on the part
of the executive
branch while it has been challenging to
figure out the financial situation in
regards to the federal funding of the
state of emergency I have spoken to
other states who have had state agencies
do this research uh Wisconsin in
particular and I have consulted with
lawyers about the Stafford act the cares
Act and the Consolidated Appropriations
act ultimately it seems that because we
are in a national state of emergency we
do not need New Hampshire to be in a
state of emergency to receive support
from these
acts this resolution is not meant to be
a criticism of the covid-19 mitigation
Strategies employed by the executive
branch nor is it a statement that the
pandemic is over it is a declaration
that we are restoring our Republic in a
letter to William Hunter Thomas
Jefferson wrote the Republican is the
only form of government which is not
eternally at open or secret war with the
rights of mankind in conclusion it is
time to restore our constitutional
republic by ending the state of
emergency to protect the health safety
and the liberty of the people of New
Hampshire thank you representative um we
we willing to take questions
of
course there any questions in the
committee room any questions from the
participants in
Zoom seeing none thank you very
much will you be submitting that written
testimony I certainly can yes thank you
thank
you chair recognizes representative
lakas thank you and first I'd like to
apologize to those on Zoom given the
setup here I have to turn my back on
some well thank you thank you uh Mr
chairman and committee I'm Tony luus
representing Hillsboro County District
37 the towns of Hudson and pelum while
Co has been a serious health problem and
many have died of it many others have
died or been otherwise harmed by the
response to co while the covid deaths
are before us in the news almost daily
the harm caused by Co is less obvious
but just as real a study by the National
Bureau of economic research concluded
that the pandemic and recession were
associated with 10 to 60% increase in
deaths of Despair above the already high
prepandemic levels that study as well as
the CDC also concluded that opioid
overdoses were the highest ever recorded
in a 12-month period in 2020
while unemployment benefits have been
increased and extended according to the
US Bureau of Labor Statistics over 40%
of those who lost their jobs due to the
emergency mandates are not expected to
regain them by November 2020 more than
100 million Americans were not working
which is up over 9 million from the same
in
2019 unemployment is associated with a
60% increase in mortality and this
impact is likely to continue long after
the emergency mandates have ended
looking at the projected levels of
unemployment from 2020 to 2029 according
to Robert Graham Center for policy
studies and family medicine and Primary
Care they estimate over 70 sorry over
27,000 additional suicides if the co
restrictions end immediately and over
154,000 additional suicides if they last
longer the study published in Lancet
Psychiatry found a nine-fold higher
number of suicides associated with
unemployment unemployment is not the
only source of harm caused by the
response to the pandemic social
isolation and loss of close social
contact raise raises the risks of heart
attack and stroke and increases death
from all causes by 50% the Kaiser Family
Foundation researchers reported stress
symptoms had nearly doubled since March
2020 including difficulty sleeping
Eating Disorders increased drinking and
substance abuse and worsen worsening of
chronic health conditions the impacts of
the emergency mandates fall particularly
harshly on minorities and the those of
lower socio economic status qu the
Federal Reserve Bank of New York report
the number of active black small
business owners fell 41% from February
through April that's almost uh half in a
metaanalysis published by Frontiers and
Psychiatry 24 studies concluded the
covid prevention and mitigation efforts
resulted in vulnerable populations such
as psychiatric patients low individuals
and minorities being put at high risk
for mental distress and self harm even
if you believe that the threat from Co
Justified the state of
emergency which I believe it it did
especially initially when we weren't
sure how bad it would be we need to end
it as soon as possible to reduce the
future harm it will cause to start to
recover from its impact especially on
those least able to deal with it uh
thank you Mr chairman and committee for
your time I sent I can uh send a copy of
this if you like and I sent um another
sheet with links to the studies I've uh
quoted from and uh and others as well
thank you and I'll be glad to take
questions you will take questions I will
are there any
questions Mr chair when people are
introduced can you let us know whether
for or against the bill right up front
please thank you excellent idea um as
far as I
know you are a co-sponsor you are in
favor of yes thank you Mr chairman um I
should have said that I do see a hand up
representative speedia yes thank you Mr
chairman just um just a quick question
um representative lakas would you
believe that you know disparities in
mental health for minorities was already
already high and before the covid uh
pandemic um yes I would and and it's
just gotten worse um the last
year thank you thank
you no further
questions thank you very much thank you
Mr chairman um I understand that
sponsors have a um an expert on
the
okay representative
kushman can you hear
us
I can hear you can you hear me yes we
can thank you and welcome to legislative
Administration thank you thank you Mr
chairman and members of the committee
I'm representative Leah kushman from we
I serve on the health human services and
elderly Affairs committee and I'm
speaking today in support of
hcr2 as a registered nurse health is
very important to me as an American a
resident of New Hampshire and as a
legislator the rights of individuals are
also very important to me when
considering appropriate government
action in mitigating communicable
diseases is vital that a balance is
maintained so that policies implemented
are as least restrictive as possible in
relation to the level of threat to the
public after examining the toll of
covid-19 on New Hampshire and the
measures taken by government to mitigate
it it is clear to me that the state of
emergency declared by the governor is no
longer
necessary every death is a tragedy and
the information I will be providing in
my testimony is no in no way meant to
minim the pain that families who have
lost loved ones have endured the
forthcoming information provides context
and
perspective according to New Hampshire
do division of Vital Records a total of
13532 people died in New Hampshire in
2020 and of those deaths 85 or 6% died
with covid-19 according to New Hampshire
DHHS 12% of the total population of New
Hampshire are aged 70 and older about
90% of those who have died with Co 19
are in this age group just under 80% of
all New Hampshire deaths in 2020 with
covid-19 were in long-term care
facilities additionally 60% of New
Hampshire's population are aged 0 to 49
that's about 780,000 people within this
group there are 15 total deaths with
covid-19 reported or
0.002% those 15 were all between the
ages of 20 and 49 thankfully there are
zero reported deaths with covid-19 and
anyone aged 19 and under in New
Hampshire as you can see from these
numbers the relative risk of dying with
covid-19 in New Hampshire for the
overwhelming majority of the population
is very small let's put this into
context in New Hampshire in 2020 3.5
times as many people died of heart
disease than
covid-19 3.4 times as many people died
of cancer than covid the infamous
Spanish Flu of 1918 and 1919 resulted in
the death of about 3,000 Granite Staters
which is more than three times as many
deaths with
covid-19 at a time when the population
of New Hampshire was about onethird of
what it is
today now one of the main reasons to
justify the start of and continuation of
the state of emergency in the beginning
of the covid-19 pandemic was the need to
slow the spread flatten the curve or in
other words avoid overwhelming New
Hampshire hospitals and resources
fortunately overflow facilities set up
last spring were never needed and were
soon dismantled in fact New Hampshire
hospitals never exceeded 75% capacity
throughout the entire period from March
2020 through now at its highest point in
terms of hospitalizations in early
January of 2021 only 11.6% of all
impatient beds were occupied by Co
covid-19
patients in conclusion the threat to the
general population by covid-19 does not
warrant the continuation of the state of
emergency DHHS has authority over
long-term care for facilities and the
ability to focus mitigation efforts
where they are most needed without
emergency orders the legislature is the
proper body for lawmaking not the chief
executive it is high time for restoring
the Constitutional balance of power I
urge the members of the committee to
give hcr2 an a to pass recommendation I
thank you Mr chairman for hearing my
testimony due to a time constraint this
morning I will not be taking any
questions but I will submit my testimony
via email to the committee members thank
you thank you representative uh we will
now uh so everyone on this list
representative is in support so just in
case I I skip one way thank you so so we
have um a
requested expert from Stanford
University um Mr
vachera
he on
the I am on the call uh welcome thank
you for getting up earli coming and
speaking with us oh thanks for having me
I'm
honored the floor is
yours okay thank you for uh thank you
all for having me talk uh so in these
brief REM Mars I hope to provide some
reasons behind my strong support of HR
hcr2 which if enacted will lift the
covid-19 state emergency order so I have
three arguments first
uh the availability of the covid-19
vaccines including the newly approved
Johnson and Johnson vaccine in effect
defangs the virus uh all three of the
approved vaccines are incredibly
effective in preventing hospitalizations
and deaths caused by SARS CO2 infection
and it's true even after a single dose
of even the fiser and madna vaccines um
New Hampshire has actually done a pretty
good job of vaccinating population
quickly to date by the statistics I
looked up yesterday 16 and a half% of
the population have received at least
one dose of the vaccine and 7% of
receive both doses even more importantly
New Hampshire is making good progress in
vaccinating its elderly population and
nursing home residents um think
something like 19% of New Hampshire's
population is over the age of 65 and by
my rough projection which I conducted
yesterday I anticipate that nearly all
of them will have been offered a vaccine
well before the end of March crucially I
believe nearly every nursing home
resident in New Hampshire has already
been offered a vaccine or is is about to
be uh nearly I think somewhere somewhere
between 70 80% of Co related deaths in
New Hampshire have have been linked to
nursing homes so prioritizing that
population vaccine has yielded already
and will continue to yield a great
return in terms of reduced morbidity and
mortality associated with covid
infection it's no accident that the
covid death rate in New Hampshire has
dropped by a factor of 10 from its peak
of one death per 100,000 residents on
January 8th to 0.1 death per 100,000
resence the end of
February a 10 times drop the population
over 70 faces a much High higher risk of
mortality after infection than does the
population under 70 according to data
published by the World Health
Organization the infection survival rate
for people under 70 is
99.95% while it's only 95% for people
over 70 the older population protected
by vacine uh once that happens we will
never again see the high death count
from the virus that we saw last year the
vaccine transforms this epidemic from an
absolutely deadly terrible epidemic and
something much much much more
manageable second the harms from the
lockdown are manifold and devastating
including worse cardiovascular disease
outcomes less cancer screening
deteriorating mental health to name a
few the social isolation induced by the
lockdowns and the and the the state of
emergency had led to Sharp rise in
opioid and drug related overdoses
similar to the deaths of dispair that
occurred during the the 2008 Great
Recession social isolation of the
elderly has contributed to a sharp rise
in dementia related deaths around the
country for children the cessation of
inperson schooling and and the
replacement of inperson schooling with
with on online schooling or or in hybrid
schooling with with severe restrictions
has led to catastrophic learning losses
with with severe adverse consequences
for affected students lifespans
according to CDC estimate one in four
young adults this past June seriously
considered suicide one in three adults
worldwide are clinically depressed or
anxious as a with clinical anxiety
during the lockdown um the state of
emergency has had absolutely devastating
effects even on populations where covid
poses a relatively small LK I said the
99.95% survival for people under 70 the
harms of the lockdown are unequally
distributed economists have found that
only 37% of jobs in the US can be
performed wholly online and high paying
jobs are over represented among that set
you I think of now of the of the
lockdowns as a as trickle down
epidemiology they've served to protect
the relatively well off while exposing
the relatively poor to the infection um
third and finally once the vulnerable
population is protected the vaccine the
imposition of lockdown on net on net
harms the population some of argue for a
lock time policy aims at reducing Co
spread to zero this is a foolish and
shortsighted policy goal that will
continue to the devastating harms we've
seen from the lockdown while yielding
little in terms of population health
benefit the SARS CO2 virus has none of
the epidemological properties of a
disease that can be eradicated it's too
widespread in the population worldwide
it's not good enough for disease to be
eradicated in New Hampshire but we need
to eradicate it worldwide or else
disease would constantly be reintroduced
in the population and we a cycle of
lockdowns like we've seen in New Zealand
for so far today week weeks long um with
deep uncertainty in economic outcomes uh
there are animal reservoirs for virus
including dogs cats bats mink and other
mammals eradicating human transmission
would not be enough to get rid of the
disease are we prepared to sacrifice our
pets also eradication will require
Universal vaccination but the vaccine
has not been tested in some population
who can transmit the disease including
children and pregnant women it's
unethical to mandate vaccination
populations of the vaccine has not been
tested the only human disease that's
ever been eradicated worldwide is
smallpox and that effort took decades
even with the availability of a good
vaccine SARS kotu eradication is
impossible and should not be attempted
the best policy is to protect the
vulnerable with the vaccine that is
folks in nursing homes elderly people
and others with chronic diseases that
that predispose and the poor outcomes
and end the lockdown to stop the damages
doing the population at large this can
be accomplished within with with at the
current rate of vaccination within a
month the bill under consideration by
the New Hampshire legislature would
accomplish this purpose and I stand
strongly in favor of it thank you I'm
happy to take questions if I have time
or else if I don't I I've also submitted
my testimony on um in written form thank
you very much
um are there any
questions within committee room um
seeing them on Zoom I have one question
um and I was neglectful in the beginning
uh you've been build by the prime
sponsor as an expert uh do you have uh
in in in what area is your specialty uh
sure so I am I uh I am a professor of
medicine at Stanford University I have
published um over the last two decades
uh in peerreview journals on infectious
disease epidemiology and infectious
disease policy uh I'm a I have a MD and
a PhD in uh in economics my um uh area
is Health economics extensively about
the uh Health economics and in
particular about epidemiology and health
economics including a textbook I've
written on on the subject I've written
on HIV policy H1N1 policy uh on uh uh H
uh on a whole series of of of of
articles in the pre-co era um on
infectious disease I've also during the
during uh covid I've written on um I was
I wrote the first Sero prevalence study
in Los Angeles County peer peer reviewed
measuring the extent of the spread of H
of of the SARS Co 2 virus in the early
Po in the early days of the epidemic as
well I've written on evaluating the the
consequences and the efficacy of the
lockdown again in peer rreview journals
so I've been I've doing a lot of work on
hi on on um sarov 2 and on on covid and
in particular on on on this policy I'm
also the co-author of the great
barington declaration which is a uh a uh
basically it's an argument for focused
protection of the of the uh of the of
the the people most vulnerable um to the
SARS 2
infection thank you um one last question
uh did I understand you just say that
you were uh supportive of mandatory
vaccinations no no I'm against mandatory
vaccination I think it's unethical to
mandate the vacc vaccine in in
populations for whom it has not been
tested so for instance there are no
peer-reviewed testing of the vaccine in
children you could not you should not be
vanting in children and for instance all
same thing with pregnant women it's not
there's no uh peer-reviewed evaluation
of the vaccine in in in you know
randomized valuations in pregnant women
so I don't think it's it would be right
to mandate the vaccine that those
populations I'm also against mandating
vaccine more broadly I think the vaccine
is an incredibly important tool it's and
and has been shown to be effective in
some populations and I think Public
Health should strongly recommend in
favor of the vaccine but I think a
mandating the vaccine would harm Public
Health in in in ways I didn't discuss in
my in my comments but I'm happy to
elaborate on if you'd like
thank you very much uh any further
questions seeing none thank you again
thank
you on the list here oh okay um the
chair would like to call David Martin
who would like to speak in support of
hdr2 Mr
Martin you need to unmute
there you
go good morning thank you good morning
uh Mr chair in in recognition of the uh
previous comment I will dispense with
the credentials
first um I I am the founder of the first
medical device contract resear research
organization at the University of
Virginia um IDM Med my background has
been in over three decades of conducting
clinical trials my faculty positions
were in the department of radiology and
orthopedic surgery in the medical school
and in addition to that I have since
1999 been an asset to the United States
and foreign governments on studying the
proliferation and counter proliferation
of biological and chemical weapons
violations
worldwide um something that we have been
quite concerned
with I am not going to be commenting
specifically on any of the interventions
per se but I am in strong support of HRC
2 and to put it in context my concern
comes out of a briefing that we did
several years ago when Dr Peter dashik
in February of
2016 made the following statement
published add a National Academy of
Sciences
Forum where he said we need to increase
public understanding of the need for Med
medical counter measures such as a pan
Corona virus vaccine a key driver is the
media and the economics will follow the
hype we need to use that hype to our
advantage to get to the real issues
investors will respond if they see
profit at the end of the
process we wrote a briefing at that time
suggesting that there was a significant
problem with niid n I Aid
selecting not only the Corona virus
itself but specifically the Wuhan
Institute of Urology virus one which has
a very close analog to what is currently
considered SARS
cov2 we're very concerned when we
realized that a study
conducted by researchers in the European
Journal of
epidemiology found that as many as 355
350 53
individuals between September and
November of 2019 in advance of any
disease in
Wuhan tested positive for what was
called the SARS cov2 IGG
equivalent suggesting that the SARS cov2
fragment of what is considered to be one
of the variants of SARS Corona virus was
circulating in the population at least
by by September of
2019 three months in advance at least of
China's first
report we were further troubled by the
fact that when the 100 individuals with
covid-19 between October and December of
2019 had their blood assay 67 of the
blood tests that were available out of
the 100 individuals of covid-19 were
tested for antibodies for SAR cov2 and
there were none found in other words
covid-19 the
symptoms and SAR cov2 the virus in fact
have at best a modeled but not proven
Association and that's been the case in
France that's been the case in
Europe um across Europe that's been the
case in China and it indeed is the case
here on March 13th 2020 acting on
unconfirmed misleading and foreign
supplied intelligence Governor Chris
tsunu recited false claims to justify
the Declaration of the state of
emergency with the best of
intentions in the preamble to the
Declaration he recited the causal
statement linking quote a novel Corona
virus to a disease with no evidence then
or now substantiating that
claim at the time several dozen known
variants so SAR covt C coov were
published and no clinical evidence
showed a quote virus end quote be
uniquely causing a disease in fact
according to research published in the
anals of internal medicine as many as
45% of individuals testing positive
using the
rtpcr determined infection with s cov2
fragments never manifest covid-19
symptoms whatsoever while there may be
an association
as yet unproven linking the virus to the
list of symptoms now aggregated under
covid-19 designation at the time of the
Declaration both the statement of
novelty and causality were conjecture
not
fact furthermore he stated that the
quote State of New Hampshire has been
working in close collaboration with the
CDC quote since December 2019 to Monitor
and plan for the potential spread of
covid-19 to the United states end quote
this claim test credibility as covid-19
was not identified nor named until
February 2020 and the CDC has no record
in the public of any such collaboration
so no such action has been
documented relying on computer
simulations from the United Kingdom he
recited unproven allegations about the
spread of
co9 an erroneous statement as viruses
not symptoms can
spread and he recited the fact that they
spread by respiratory droplets another
statement that has not yet been
established with any clinical evidence
and that is a very important Point while
there have been Environmental Studies
modeling the spread of how the virus may
move across time and space with the
exception of a modeled study in a
hospital setting where data collection
was done at varying proximities to a
patient while they did show that a virus
in fact did move across time and space
in that particular setting no study of
transmissivity with infectivity has ever
been established with SARS cov2 and that
remains the case today in short relying
on hearsay rather than on Independent
inquiry Governor cunu enacted a state of
emergency in coordination with others
without considering ing the ample
evidence to indicate that factors other
than public health emergency were at
play preservation of the state of
emergency serves commercial interests
federally under the prep act for limited
liability for medical countermeasures
but serves no Public Health interest and
I have submitted an extensive written
testimony to the committee um by email
yesterday thank you are you willing to
take questions I am
indeed are there any questions in the
committee room see none any on
Zoom being none thank you very much for
your testimony you're most
welcome we've concluded the 30 minutes
set aside
for um the sponsors of the plan um of
the bill we will now move on
to members of the public um you have any
ped up
chair will recognize Robert clay uh
Senator
and all around good guy
um Mr thank you thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee I just wanted
to come on today I'm in favor of house
uh concurrent resolution 2 I wanted to
come on and give people a little history
of of how we got to where we are back
after 9911 um the governor at the time
was caught in Washington DC leaving the
state of New Hampshire in a unique
position of having the Senate President
being
charged what we found out at that time
is that only the governor had access to
Emergency Management and a whole lot of
other um systems that we needed to to to
share at the time we worked out a way of
getting things done because the
government governor was stranded I think
for at least a week uh since all the
roads were were shut down what we found
during uh the 9911 time is that we were
being uh threatened with Anthrax attacks
um we also did some mock drills to see
what would happen if we were attacked
with chemical warfare and we found that
we were um extremely
unprepared um for any kind of attack and
and any kind of um work that might need
to be done so I'm giving you the short
version what we did is after we got
things rolling and and we started uh
gaining some momentum we worked not uh
as a partisan group but as a bipartisan
group we worked with the governor and we
came up with what you see in in
445 but the intent was that should we be
struck again and the legislature not be
able to meet somebody had to take
charge before before 911 the governor
could just declare an mergency and stay
forever so what we said is that we
shouldn't allow the governor to stay in
charge for more than 21 days we never
fathom that something would happen where
the legislature could never come
together and meet and take control of
what needed to be done in the state of
New Hampshire so we we said 21 days but
if we were attacked more than once or on
a continuous basis we still needed a way
to continue to lead the state which is
why we put put the provision in that
said he could renew it but again it was
never renew it with the ability of the
legislature to meet it was to renew so
that without a
legislature we continued to do what was
necessary for the State of New Hampshire
what I've seen today uh or or under the
Corona virus um emergency act um is is
totally opposite of anything we ever
fathomed as a group of people a
bipartisan group we always figured that
a governor would never want to be in
total control and the legislature would
want to meet and actually do what was
ever necessary so I'm in favor of house
concurrent resolution 2 we we put that
in by the way so that no matter what and
no matter who the legislature could come
in at any time during that 21 days and
say okay enough we're back the Republic
the Republic is going to work and we'll
take it from here it was never to stop
the constant renewal of an emergency
order so while I think that we had all
the right intentions at the time um as
Justice delus used to say if that's what
you meant make sure that's what it says
and I'm hopeful that you'll pass house
concurrent resolution to and that you'll
tweak the law as it is to say that the
governor can't just unilaterally decide
to renew an order that that gives him
total control and only allows him to do
so in a situation where the
legislature can't possibly meet together
in a quorum to actually take control and
do what's necessary thank you Mr
chairman members of the committee I'll
take any questions if you have any thank
you uh are there questions in the
committee room questions on seeing n
thank you very much for your testimony
thank
you uh just so the committee is aware uh
there's an additional 10 people that
have signed up to speak ranging from 5
minutes to zero minutes for some reason
um but and we also have one person who
has raised their hand that I saw
initially um so if the speakers could
keep their time um and their comments to
items that we have not heard before that
would be great um and to be as uh as
efficient as possible that would also be
appreciated
next uh the chair will call Elliot
axan can you hear me okay now yes we can
hear you welcome excellent thank you
very much Mr chairman thank you to the
committee my name is Elliot I live in
hookset New Hampshire I am a husband a
brother a son and an uncle I'm also a
paramedic I've dedicated my life to
helping others mostly by providing
Medical Care to those in need I spent
around three years as a young
EMT volunteering an average of 30 hours
a week to provide medical care to my
community only resigning because
paramedic school demanded my
time I'm a critical care and flight
certified paramedic which is technically
the highest level of certification that
any prehospital provider could attain in
the United States I spent spent 10 years
in Emergency Medical Services working on
an ambulance in multiple M11 agencies
and multiple Critical Care transport
agencies managing acutely and
chronically ill patients on ventilators
IV pumps and all sorts of other
equipment I've treated over 10,000
patients throughout my career my
experience also includes working in a
coronavirus Hospital in May during the
pandemic as a member of as a paramedic
and a member of their critical rapid
response team all of my experience and
research leads me to believe that Co is
not nearly as contagious as the elites
have made it seem all of my experience
and research leads me to believe that Co
is not nearly as deadly as the elites
and politicians have made it
seem however even if it were the most
contagious and deadly virus in history
of humanity the restrictions imposed by
the governor and his Regulators rival
the most tyrannical regimes that I know
of in history for some of these
restrictions to be in effect in the
supposedly free estate is nothing short
of a disgrace for for this state of
emergency to have gone on for a year and
that it remains in effect indefinitely
with no signs of ever being terminated
is
unconscionable I believe that the only
justification for a governor declaring a
state of emergency and acting without
input from the legislature is in the
presence of a real imminent threat such
as missiles literally being in the air
fired by a foreign
military Common Sense R dictate that the
governor could without consulting the
legislature order a defensive maneuver
to intercept those missiles because 30
seconds could make a big difference and
assembling A legislature for a meeting
and passing legislation would actually
have a very negative effect and could
not defend our
state but that's not what happened in
this
case in this case it was a virus that
initially was thought to maybe be an
emergency and I believe the plan
initially was for uh 15 days to slow the
spread we were all convinced by our
governor that if we all clamp down very
hard for 15 days we could get back to
normal afterwards and that if we did not
we would all die and now a year later we
are all still alive but we are living
under a dictator who has rendered this
legislature irrelevant and taken over
complete power of the state and it shows
no signs of ending if there is one thing
that I know it's what an emergency looks
like this was never an emergency
certainly not in New Hampshire and it
certainly is not an emergency today
using the force of government and police
to quarantine even a person confirmed to
be contagious with the most deadly virus
like
Ebola is difficult violates Liberty and
technically is legally and morally
questionable at best and it should be
used with the utmost caution but
politicians have gone far beyond that in
this case locking down and restricting
the movements and the Commerce and even
the breathing of individuals who are not
confirmed to have the virus this
violates due process even people who
test negative for the virus one moment
cannot legally breathe in New Hampshire
without a mask one second after a
negative test result not only is every
person presumed to be sick with the
virus it is impossible for a supposedly
free person to prove to politicians and
police that we are not sick even if we
test negative we still have to wear the
mask even if we had the virus a year ago
even if we got both
vaccines the very basis of a proper
justice system in this modern world is
the presumption of innocent until proven
guilty in the current scenario we are
all presumed to be guilty in this case
means infected and contagious with the
virus and it is impossible to prove that
one is innocent or in this case not sick
this might be comparable to a justice
system in a place like North Korea not
only have our most natural rights been
violated but this was done not by a
legislative body which somewhat
represent the people but by executive
order of one politician assuming the
power of a dictator technically speaking
issuing more than 80 emergency orders
over the past year and this body has
remained silent throughout Mr Mr can we
wrap this up yes sir I have one more
paragraph be 30 seconds making this
lockdown even more ridiculous is that
the official statistics are inflated by
100 to 1,000 fold in my expert opinion I
have a few thousand sources and an
article to this effect has been
submitted to the record already you now
have the authority to pass this
resolution hcr2 and end the state of
emergency while taking powers back to
the for the legislative body though this
will not make up for the children who
missed a year of their childhoods
because they were brainwash into
thinking they will die if they play with
their friends or even lower their mask
for an instant you could never give back
the months of time the governor took
from people who wanted nothing more than
to spend time with their parents
grandparents and other loved ones many
of which no longer have that opportunity
nor will this compensate every business
that has been permanently put out of
business by the governor many people are
referring to this current state of
emergency as child abuse or elder abuse
and it's getting harder to argue with
them and I'm starting to see their Merit
for the sake of everything cherished by
our great state I ask you to please vote
Yes on hcr2 and restore some Liberty and
personal responsibility to our citizens
please end the dictatorship thank you
I'd be happy to take
questions uh thank you uh you have
written testimony on Gathering yes I
think I already sent something a few
days ago and I'm gonna send this as well
great thank you very much are there any
questions in the committee seeing none
thank you very much for your
help um next the chair will call The
Honorable
Jeffy can you hear can you unmute please
y there you go oh yes thank yes thank
you Mr chair thank you committee members
former representative Jeff olgy I'll be
very brief there are a thousand reasons
why I hope you support hcr2 I won't
review them with you today one of one of
your speakers uh by the name of David I
believe uh had some very uh good
information it was rather technical I
would ask if he could give us a one one
or two sentence blurb on his summary if
he's still available that would be
terrific I am an engineer by trade um
and I found his his uh dissertation very
informative but rather Technical and a
little bit overwhelming on on
information the bottom line is and the
reason I support this is as as Ronald
Reagan said I'm from the government I'm
here to help and gez that doesn't always
work so well our governor in in in his
defense he assembled a large diverse
team to guide him on this issue uh
almost a year ago now and what have we
gotten I I'll summarize by saying what I
think we got was a mistake this is a
mistake this lockdown these these uh
state of emergency has been a mistake
for many months now as you've heard
previous testimony uh this should have
been cancelled long ago um I'm a student
of Statistics myself and despite all of
the experts advising the governor there
is no statistical basis uh to conclude
that this the state of emergency should
have progressed the way it has simply
none um so I will end it there I I urge
you please support uh ending this uh
this problem and I think this is a case
study that shows that if we assemble a
large group of politicians we all don't
necessarily get the right answer our
governor decided to decided to take the
route which was comfortable and
favorable to many people under the guise
of empathy and protecting you uh as
opposed to promoting personal
responsibility and asking you to protect
yourself if you are an atrisk person
that's that's it for my comments thanks
for hearing me I I will uh I will take
no questions thank
you uh Rabbi
aqu you have to
unmute hello can you hear me we can
thank you and welcome
good morning and thank you for this
opportunity to speak in favor of
hcr2 my name is stepen axelman and for
the last 17 years I have served as the
rabbi of a synagogue in New York City I
am also credential as a licensed
clinical social worker in New York and
New Jersey and formerly in Maryland
though I do not currently practice as a
psychotherapist over the last year my
synagogue has gone through several
months of not holding any in-person
services including over last year's
Passover holiday the most celebrated
event of the Jewish year the Passover
seder was closed off to almost everyone
during the high holidays last September
the second most observed events of the
Jewish year only a limited number of
persons were able to attend services in
person last July we reopened our
synagogue on a volun AR basis with
attendees wearing masks and being
socially distanced during services with
Refreshments available afterwards for
those who wanted to stay our attendees
range in age from 25 to the upper 80s I
am proud to say that not one of our
attendees since July has contracted
covid my main message is the incredible
painful loneliness that people
especially the elderly have gone through
over the last 11 months many of them
basically locked in their own homes
without being able to see their friends
children grandchildren and
great-grandchildren
the saddest part of this situation is
known to me through my officiating at
funerals I do not deny that many people
have and are dying of covid but hearing
so many stories of loved ones taking
their elderly relatives to hospitals
dropping them off outside an emergency
room and not being able to be with them
in person at any time until they pass is
indescribably painful for both sides I
do not know how anyone from a
psychological or spiritual perspective
could make the argument that there is
not a severe negative effect on people
from being socially isolated banned from
touch and even being in the same same
room of a Dying loved
one all of life is a balance of risks
and benefits that should always remain
in the discretion of the individuals and
families who are the only ones who can
realistically assess their situations
and do what is best for each person New
Hampshire the Live Free or Die State
should never be allowed to become as
unfree as the state in which I live and
it is within yourth authority to make
sure that never happens thank you I'd be
happy to answer any
questions thank you uh are there any
questions not in the committee room any
on
Zoom not that I can see thank you very
much uh it appears you had written
testimony have you submitted that I have
not but I could thank you that would be
wonderful thank you um next the
chair
uh the chair will call Ed
Maslin good morning can you hear me yes
we can welcome thank
you good morning my name is Ed Mish I
was invited to give testimony and
support of the resolution by Melissa
blasek one of the supporters of the of
the resolution I have been a practicing
attorney for 25 years and I have
litigated constitutional law cases
although admittedly I have never
litigated constitutional analogous to
the issue before the committee today
that's because the issue before the
committee today is unprecedented in
American history with the possible
exception of the Japanese internment
camps before I focus on the individual
trees of the forest that make the
current emergency order unconstitutional
I think it makes sense to begin by
focusing on the forest itself
Constitutions are written not for the
purpose of giving government broad
Powers rather Constitutions are written
for the purpose of limiting government
power in order to promote human
flourishing and individual liberty
indeed article one and two of the New
Hampshire Bill of Rights specifically
provide that all individuals are born
free and independent and have the
inherent right to seek and obtain
happiness in accordance with their own
judgment the emergency order and the
reasons offered in support of it
contradict those foundational principles
of constitutional government one of the
foundational principles of a free
Society is the presumption of innocence
again that presumption of innocence is
implied In Articles 1 and two of the New
Hampshire Bill of Rights people born
free and independent with the inherent
right to seek and obtain happiness are
necessarily in until proven guilty
indeed if one studies the history of the
American Revolution it was fought as
much over the opposition to taxation
without representation as it was over
the Crown's use of General warrants
known as rits of assistance articles
article 2B of the New Hampshire
Constitution codifies the protection by
providing that an individual's right to
live free from government intrusion in
private and personal affairs is natural
inessential and inherent but the
emergency order does not treat all
individuals as free and independent it
does not start with a presumption that
individuals have a right to privacy what
they right to seek and obtain happiness
according to their judgment nor does it
start with a presumption of innocence
instead the broad emergency powers
exercised by the executive under this
emergency order presumes all individuals
either have covid or are spreaders of
covid for the first time in American
history we are quarantining not just
people who have been specifically
identified as having a contagious and
communicable disease instead the
emergency order serves as a general
warrant limiting the freedom of all
individuals in New Hampshire including
those for whom there is no evidence of
Co infection further even those who
prove that they do not have covid are
treated as though they have covid this
is completely different from the
quarantines that took place at Ellis
Island with regard to immigrants who
were inspected and found to have a
communicable disease is also completely
different from De side a more modern
example the quarantine of individuals
who contracted the Ebola virus
quarantining the sick is different in
kind from quarantining everyone
including those For Whom the government
has no specific evidence of infection I
challenge any supporter of the emergency
order to articulate any private conduct
that is immune from restriction by the
governor should the governor simply
assert a connection between the conduct
and stopping the spread of covid does
the governor have the power to order
under the order to send the National
Guard to people's homes to inspect and
confirm that all individuals in the
dwelling do not have covid and are
practicing social distancing does the
governor have the power to send the
National Guard to private dwellings and
compel individuals to be vaccinated more
generally can the supporters of the
governor's emergency Powers articulate
any limiting principle to the executives
power under this emergency order I do
not see any such limiting principle
turning quickly to the trees here is a
brief list of the Constitutional
Provisions I believe the emergency order
violates from the New Hampshire Bill of
Rights Article one's guarantee that all
men are born free and independent
article two is guarantee that all
individuals have the right to acquire
property and seek and obtain happiness
according to their own judgment article
2B is a guarantee of the individual's
right to privacy article 5's guarantee
that no man shall be restrained in the
exercise of his religious worship
article 15's guarantee of among other
things the presumption of innocence
article 19's prohibition on the use of
General warrants by the executive
article 29's requirement that any
suspension of law be exercised by the by
the legislature not any other branch of
the government in article 37's guarantee
of a separation of powers between the
legislative executive and judicial
branches the emergency powers exercised
by the Executive also violate the
provisions of the New Hampshire
Constitution set forth in part two
relating to form of government
specifically the emergency Powers
violate Article 2 which vests all
legislative power in the House of
Representatives and Senate not the not
the executive Article 5 which likewise
recognizes only the legislator
possessing the power to exercise
legislative powers article 41 which
grants the executive only the power to
Faithfully execute the laws not to make
laws and the latter half of article 83
which guarantees free and Fair
competition in trades and industries for
all people I note further that the
provisions of article 51 strongly
suggest that the emergency Powers
currently being exercised exceed the
Constitutional grant of authority to the
executive article 51 states that even in
times of insurrection and Invasion the
governor as commander-in-chief still
must exercise emergency Powers
consistent with all rules regulations
and the constitution of the state thus
even in so far as a statute delegating
emergency power from the legislature to
the governor purports to Grant the
governor power to violate separation of
powers and support and suspend
constitutional guarantees such
delegation itself violates article 51
not to mention articles 2 and five of
part two of the State Constitution
furthermore there is little doubt that
as bad as Co May
is certainly not a greater emergency
than Insurrection or Invasion the
emergency powers exercised by the
executive here also violate Pro
provisions of the Federal Constitution
including article 4 section 4's
guarantee of a republican form of
government as well as analogous Federal
guarantees as set forth above in the New
Hampshire Constitution but because my
time is limited I won't get into those
thank you if you have questions I'm here
to take them thank you for your
testimony are there any
questions are you you submitting written
testimony I will submit what I've just
spoken yes thank you very much that
would be wonderful I see no other
questions appreciate your help thank you
thank
you keep moving down then
we'll go
to
speak Andrew
man honorable Andrew manuse the chair
will
call
welcome thank you uh honorable members
of the committee um I'm former
representative Andrew manuse husband
father businessman writing is a a
citizen I submitted a written testimony
to you by email uh last night um I'm in
favor of passing hcr2 and ending the
state of emergency immediately For
Better or Worse the people's Authority
that you represent has been usurped by
the executive branch and this state of
lawlessness has persisted well beyond
any reasonable time period as such many
businesses and organizations who have
been harmed the most by the owner of
shutdowns and authoritarian restrictions
have been fined and threatened with
fines assuming a degree of normaly as
they attempt to survive I want to focus
on the word survive it's a term that has
not been used in well over a hundred
years in the state of New Hampshire it's
imperative that we restore our
constitutional republic and the old
normal immediately to ensure that these
businesses can operate with a fair and
balanced rule of law as they were
accustomed to before which protects the
minority from the majority what this
Governor has instituted is a state of
lawlessness there is no no law being
followed whether you or not you agree
with the content of the copious
emergency orders passed by the chief
executive since March or the persistent
state of emergency that has well
surpassed an expectation of the writer
of RSA 445 which you heard earlier Bob
CLE uh the fact of the matter is that
your legislative body ought to be
writing State policy the courts ought to
be adjudicating disputes and the
governor ought to be enforcing law
rather than assuming all three of the
duties for himself one might argue that
the ideas in some of the governor's
emergency orders might not pass if left
to the legislature but that is precisely
the point of having a separation of
powers in our government no one man or
woman should be writing policy for more
than a million people with without any
checks on his power the Constitutional
process ensures that policies are for
the public good and others that do not
measure up to the body's consensus ought
not to be law this isn't about one
Governor but about any Governor at any
time we have a legislature and a
constitutional process for proposing and
adopting State policy after has been
fully vetted by the public to make sure
it's constitutional and useful for
building up the people's Liberty and
securing their rights it's now time for
you to ensure this power is restored by
ending the state of
emergency uh many people have commented
about the governor's popularity is a
rationale for not ending the state of
emergency um but I would remind you that
we don't live in a democracy where the
majority rules or the most praised idea
wins the day even the best ideas ought
to be vetted and held up to a standard
of law written into the Constitution to
ensure that the minority's rights are
protected if 99 people for example out
of a 100 think that the one person's
land that he purchased and developed
under the law is better suited to
another private purpose it doesn't
matter we have a constitutional
provision that prohibits the majority
from taking the land because that one
person has rights that matter the point
of the example is that we have laws in
this state that you may have even helped
write and these laws are being
disregarded by our governor right now
they shouldn't be as the Constitution
makes clear only the legislature or the
people have the authority to suspend or
create laws the governor and other
executive branch officials do not have
that Authority uh even in a state of
emergency under RSA 445 and related
statutes the governor May suspend rules
or regulations passed by the executive
branch of government
but by no means me may he suspend law or
the Constitution or write new law
himself however he's doing just that
under the color of law with his
emergency orders and it has to end now
there is no higher priority than making
uh hcr2 uh into a adopted resolution as
of today if if it's at all possible I
have nothing to gain by making these
statements or this request of you and
everything to lose I simply want to get
back to the way of life I know to be
best suited for for providing the most
people with the best chance of a
fulfilling life I want that for my
children my wife my church my clients
and the people of this state I want to
make sure that no Governor could ever do
again what this Governor has done for
there is no emergency that warrants the
total control of one man the idea is
anathema to this country I ask you to
stand together Republicans and Democrats
in boldness and end this onean rule in
New Hampshire restore our constitutional
republic without fear and know and know
that well Messi a free Society does more
good for more people than any other
system that has ever been tried please
patch HCR to so we can get back to it
and um I I don't think I'll take
questions thank you thank you for your
testimony good to see you
again CH
call Julie
Tucker just so the committee knows we
now have uh five people additionally
raising hands and we
have five people left to speak
on um seven people
raising um Julie Tucker are you unmuted
yes I'm I'm here hello welcome thank you
for letting me speak as a New Hampshire
citizen I cannot believe that we the
people have been living under the orders
of one person for 11 months without any
representation or input this is not how
a representative democracy
works this is how a dictatorship works
you we have elected you the legislator
to be our the people's Representatives
so I certainly hope you will support
hcr2 especially giving the medical facts
that have come out over the last 11
months these orders have shown
themselves to be arbitrary and have had
a great impact on us We the People our
ability to earn a living have input in
the Democratic process gain access to
Municipal services that we pay for our
right to breathe and our right to live
normal I haven't seen my father in
months he's 91 because he's locked up
there is no evidence that these rules do
anything to stop the spread of covid-19
this is a dangerous precedent that is
being set and one that should not be
allowed in any free Society again we
have elected you you to be the voice of
us to represent the people and ensure
our voice is heard please stop letting
us down and end this order thank
you thank you uh do you have written
testimony I sent an email to the
committee I don't know if that's written
testimony oh that is great um will you
be willing to take questions
yes spoke to
um I see no questions thank you very
much for your testimony thank
you
John uh chair recognizes John
Schmid can you hear me I we can
welcome you're you're W up you're
welcome to go no don't have any
sorry Mr schmi can you hear us I can
hear you can you hear me H now we can
welcome well thank you thank you for the
opportunity I want to bring up something
a little bit different I agree with
everybody about constitutional rights
and all that stuff but I just want to
bring something up about this emergency
I don't think we ever had an emergency
and if you do some research on the germ
theory of disease versus the terrain
theory of disease uh the terrain theory
is what everything is based on and it's
unproven and this whole thing is based
on PCR tests which again the inventor of
the PCR test Nobel Prize winner Carrie
Mullis said you can't use it to diagnose
any disease yet we're diagnosing this
covid-19 non-existing virus with this
thing in healthy people they've never
isolated this virus they've never proved
it exists or causes sickness that's the
science at least my opinion so where are
we at now we can't even breathe in New
Hampshire under these crazy Emperor
edicts businesses are being destroyed
spending is reckless federal and
state uh the real virus is governments
federal state and local it's also the
medical industrial complex which is
greatly profiting off this whole
scamdemic and continues to push this
thing and of course they want to push
the vaccines on us so they can make $50
billion a year so in conclusion I would
ask what some other people have asked
let's go back to the Live Free or Die
State let's let the people live freely
forget these emergency nonsense orders
from the emperor and let's not live in
fear of dying from this covid sniffle
thank
you thank you Mr do you have written
testimony that you are submitting I will
submit it I haven't yet but will thank
you thank you uh would you take question
I'll take all the questions you
want seeing none on the inside any
online so far none thank you very much
for your test thank
you how about the others that we jumped
over
back
go all we jumped over the list of P yeah
I don't see
them uh okay
uh Doris
honesy you would me you
mute good morning good morning
thank you for letting me testim uh
testify my name is darus heny I'm in
NASA I'm a former School Board member
and I'm in support of this
resolution I in in order to be brief
I'll eliminate my testimony that I have
submitted and hit on a couple of points
that are Germaine to
NASA the authorization for municipal
governments to remain Clos indefinitely
under this um state of emergency has
allowed Nashville police to arrest
arrested a whistleblower for Criminal
Trespass when she sought public
information to help elderly citizens
file property abatement request as
prescribed by the deadline March 1st the
nashille assessing office remains closed
officially but you have to have an
appointment and they refuse to give this
citizen any appointments so she now has
a criminal trespass charge and this was
enabled by this state of emergency last
year the school district approved a
district budget without a public Hearing
in violation of state law we have the
second largest District in the state and
the budget's over 100 $150 million a
year the school board refused to meet in
person and did not allow public comment
for 10 months no public comment during
all of its virtual meetings virtual
meetings are it just means we have no
self-government and it violates the
right to to no law I was personally
slapped with a restraining order for
taking a picture of a board member at a
local post office to prove that she left
her house even though she claims she's
unable to do so and meet other than in
Virtual meetings the government state of
emergency allowed the court to deny me
the right to face my accuser in public
just another constitutional violation
enabled by sonunu also the elderly this
is horrible what they are doing to every
elderly person in this state I am a
caregiver for my mother and her twin who
are 96 years old they are isol ated they
are mentally and physically
deteriorating I was nearly arrested in
the dairy hospital I'm not allowed in I
was outside in the dark in the rain in
an empty parking lot and two very nice
police officers told me if I didn't wait
in my car that they would call the
station and have me
arrested I I won't go any further this
this has to stop this is horrible we
just have the legislature is now
complicit it needs to stop this it needs
to legis late and I thank you and I'll
take I I'll take any questions you
have than you are there any
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony you're
welcome that'd be great um chair
recognizes James
coners I hope I pronounced that right
need to unmute Mr
Conor so sorry about that I was having
some connectivity issues I apologize um
no worries welcome to legislative
Administration thank you for the
opportunity to speak to the committee
today my name is James Conor a resident
of Amherst and I'm testifying as a
member of the public in support of hcr2
I prepared a written testimony by email
to the committee uh but I'd like to just
highlight a few brief points at this
time about some of the data available
regarding overall mortality in 2020 um
so to put to sidestep debates we hear
about case counts and testing methods
one objective method to gauge the
severity of widespread disease is the
total number of people who have died in
a given state in a given year uh so
using data available from New Hampshire
Department of States division of Vital
Records and applying a typ typical age
adjustment methodology to account for
demographic and population changes
year-over-year the 2020 ended up being
the ninth highest year of overall deaths
in the last 20 years lower than most of
the first decade of the 21st century um
when you break down the data into age
specific rates uh all age brackets
showed no discernable change from uh the
last several years except for the age 85
Plus bracket which has the highest
observe rate since 2002 and this makes
sense as New Hampshire DHHS reports that
two-thirds of all reported deaths with
covid-19 in New Hampshire are from those
over 80 years old all other age brackets
which is to say those under 74 years old
saw no discernable change from recent
years so what that means according to
New Hampshire's own published numbers is
that the overall rate of death for those
under age 85 was essentially unchanged
in 2020 and on a More granar Level if
you compare the all cause age adjusted
death rate by month in 2020 to the
maximum minimum range going back about
15 years it reveals another interesting
Trend we did DC a spike in May of 2020
it had an abnormally High rate of death
above the maximum oberved range in
recent past but the rest of the year
range from average to a little above
average but all within the range of
recent
experience so all this um all this is uh
you know while there' be more statistics
and data sets to examine over time it's
clear from looking at the data available
11 months into the state of emergency
that for all but the extremely elderly
and those with significant underlying
conditions Co is not a uniquely fatal
Disease by the data that that that's
available and it reinforces the plain
fact that children are at in incredibly
low risk with not a single recorded
covid death of anyone under the age of
20 in New Hampshire so this is all not
in this focus on mortality is not
intended to downplay the seriousness of
a respiratory disease that has claimed
the lives of hundreds of grand Staters
over the last year but we do need to
evaluate situations like this and our
response to them through the lens of
History common sense and available data
the overall mortality for 2020 combined
with weekly published data from the
national HHS shows that the hospitals in
New Hampshire have not been at risk
being overwhelmed and this demonstrates
the entire basis for governor andun
continuing this state of emergency is
wrong we have real world data that shows
how risky and deadly this disease is to
the general population so we have no
excuse to continue to act as if this is
still march of 2020 when we didn't have
a good idea of what was going going on
legislature must reclaim their governing
authority to put an end to the
government by executive order that has
gone on for far too long I urge this
committee to support hcr2 and end the
state of emergency thank you for your
time and
attention thank you for your testimony
uh will you take questions if there's
any
yes are there any questions
anyone uh seeing none uh thank for your
testimony thank
you chair recognizes Joseph
perelli need to unmute Mr
pelli there you
go welcome toar Administration yes we
can hear you yeah thank you hi good
morning everyone just wanted to speak in
support of this bill U just Echo the
comments they already made made great
comments All in support of the bill
regarding the reasons for the emergency
order in the first place I just to
ensure that hospitals weren't
overwhelmed um and we've seen an
improved situation in Co in the
state and
uh excuse me um the uh the lockdown
seems to have done real number on our
society it's caused a lot of uh
separation uh issues of mental health
job losses um and uh
cause people to be separated when onside
communities um I think that we have uh
We've W our 16th renewal of the
emergency order and the next one's
coming up on Friday and I'm hoping that
the governor sees it as a issue for
legislation to deal with I hope you all
see it that way as well perhaps decides
not to renew the order um but as regards
the hdr2 I think it's a great bill of
support um I think that we need to
understand as been mentioned before um
that uh we're in a better situation than
we were initially and it was very common
for governors in the
beginning see this as a state of
emergency and decide to
um you know act in you know
understandable haste um and they
recently preferred looking back and
saying that they overreacted over the
alternative um and now that we're
looking back though we could see that
there were some more reactions and how
we responded um and now we're at the
situation we have vaccines available and
we really can't get control over
this and as we look forward uh I
hopefully we all remember that uh while
the state has broad police powers to
respond to emergencies that threaten
public health and safety they're still
limited by the US Constitution our own
state constitution and laws we have in
place um and uh we should all do utmost
to avoid abridging citizens rights and
uh with that I'll close my comments
unfortunately I don't have any written
comments to submit but uh I will get
something on an email to all and thank
you thank you uh you don't lose points
for not having written testimony
you're will you take
questions unfortunately not I'm I'm
sorry I'm on the road right now that's
fine uh thank you very much for your
testimony thank
you Tammy Clark um chair recognizes
Tammy Clark please
unmute there you go good morning can you
hear me uh we can thank you and welcome
okay thank you very much I was invited
to speak today by representative uh
Melissa BC and um I just wanted to offer
some expert um testimony on the whole
issue regarding face masks and the
mandatory wearing of PPE I am by by
career a credentialed OSHA credentialed
environmental and occupational health
and safety compliance expert I'm a court
approved legal expert subject matter
expert on all things health safety
compliance and PPE related when this
when these mandates first came out it
was people like me industrial hygienists
environmental occupational health and
safety professionals that really started
speaking up because what we are doing in
mandating the forced wearing of face
masks really flies in the face of Osha
standards for
example in the workplace in the work
environment when there is a known Hazard
when there is a risk of Hazard exposure
an occupational health and safety expert
will do a risk analysis to determine
what the employee or what the people are
exposed to from that point they follow
what is called the hierarchy of safety
and controls PPE is always the last line
of defense we never ever mandatorily use
a
one-size one-size blanket one-size
fits-all mandate to put people in any
type of PPE especially respiratory
protection this is the reason OSHA
created the respiratory protection
standard and the PPE standards in
1979 by covering the mouth and nose
exerting energy and going about our work
tasks we were giving people heart
attacks it is very taxing on the
cardiopulmonary system to cover the
mouth and nose forcibly require someone
to go about their their business their
work exert energy without controlling
the environment temperature humidity and
implementing what's called work rest
Cycles in other words the covering of
the mouth and nose inhibits oxygen
intake by up to 20% this is proven and
documented by Nash and OSHA's own
studies going back to
1970 what OSHA has done and what the
government has done has bypassed all of
the hierarchy of safety and controls and
they have completely swept decades worth
of Science and data on the wearing of
face masks on the use of PPE and they
have swept it under the rug as if it
does not exist those in my career field
have been trying to sound the alarm but
we have been silenced there is not one
industrial hygienist environmental
health and safety professional or
occupational health and safety
professional or an occupational doctor
for that matter on any of these covid-19
task force why is that because they
don't want to hear from us what we are
saying is we are taking the absolute
wrong approach and we are creating a
greater Hazard for the population not
only for working in individuals but also
for children the forced wearing of masks
is extremely dangerous we know this we
have the tests we have the data we have
the science we have randomized control
tests which is the mother of all
scientific tests with meta analysis
going back to the early 1970s on all of
this and yet they're telling us just
cover your mouth and nose with whatever
cloth
surgical masks homemade face mask it
doesn't matter they're telling you that
will protect you and it is absolutely
false we have test after test after test
that show not only does a surgical mask
or a cloth mask not protect you from
respiratory viral transmission but it
also creates a greater
Hazard this is why in a hospital setting
doctors nurses and healthcare workers
when they wear surgical masks which by
the way are not designed or rated to
protect against a virus they are only
rated to protect against bacterial
splashes this is why there is rampant
infection among healthc care workers in
hospitals with respiratory illnesses
like influenza flu and things like this
they have studied this why is it that
healthcare workers are wearing surgical
masks yet they pass the flu respiratory
illnesses pass like crazy well that's
because the PPE that they're wearing is
not designed or rated to protect against
viral transmission of respiratory
infectious diseases so we know we know
through testing we know through studies
which is very well documented and I will
submit in my written
testimony that we cannot use anything
that is homemade cloth s surgical masks
Etc to protect the wearer or somebody
nearby the wearer from the spread of an
infectious disease through a viron the
viruses are so tiny they will pass
through the membrane of that material
the only PPE that is rated and tested
that will what that will knowingly
protect the wearer or those nearby the
wearer from the spread of infectious
disease through Von is what's called a
cap APR or a PPR these are the Big
Spaceship looking hoods
anybody working on an infectious disease
Ward you will see them working in these
big self-contained
respirators they are not wearing
surgical masks on infectious disease
Wards there's a reason for this so to
take this approach that we're just going
to mandate everybody wear a face mask is
so irresponsible it is so unethical and
it drives me crazy because I look around
and I see all these kids that are very
very sensitive to oxygen saturation and
I see all these children wearing face
masks I see everyday people walking
around in face masks and yet their their
um environment is not a microcontrolled
environment such as a surgical center or
a hospital and this is this is why
doctors and nurses work in a carefully
controlled environment because they are
wearing face coverings so the
temperature is lower the humidity is
lower the oxygen output is higher there
are increased additional air cycle
exchanges
for a reason because they're working
with their mouth and nose covered even
then they have to stop and take work
rest Cycles they are trained on how to
properly done and do that mask are we
all trained in the public no so people
are touching these Mas we have to wrap
this up a little bit
okay
so overall I just wanted to offer my
expert professional um testimony because
because what these government officials
are doing is putting the population at
Great risk there's no training for the
for the public they are we are seeing
the infectious diseases like bacterial
pneumonia staff uh perioral dermatitis
Skyrocket and that is a direct result of
inappropriate and irresponsible
mandating of PPE wearing without
following the OSHA
standards thank you uh will you take
questions from the committee
sure are there any questions from the
committee seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank
you uh we have
a we have someone named Leslie with her
hand
raised chair recognizes Les
you would have to
rute
Leslie hello hello Leslie Hi how are you
fine thank you can you tell us your full
name sure my name is Leslie
Tatro I live in Warren New Hampshire I'm
sorry could you spell your last name
sure it's t as in Tom e t r a u l
t one more time sure t as in Tom e t as
in Tom r a u l
t thank you very much thank you well
welcome to legislative Administration do
you have testimony for us uh yes yes I
do I moved here to New Hampshire in 2012
for many reasons um one of them was at
one time we were considered the state
with the most personal Liberties and to
me um someone who follow the
Constitution I like the idea of that um
I like what everybody else has said and
I would like to talk about what I see um
first of all we are live for your die
and what I see is uh people are dying in
order to be safe but I feel that safety
is an illusion I wonder what the
statistics are for people who get in
their car and drive on the highway
what's your what's your uh your sta
sorry your chance of being killed while
you're in a car anytime you walk outside
of your house the the chances of you
being killed are much greater than the 0
one% I believe from this um virus and
I'd like to say I'm a retired teacher
from Florida lived there for a while and
I think about all those kids I work with
special needs kids I I wonder how they
are managing to deal with having to have
their faces covered these are children
already are medically very fragile
emotionally very fragile um and that's
the thing that makes me the most sad is
I see kids I hear about kids harming
themselves cutting themselves wanting to
kill themselves because they are so
socially isolated and they see no future
for themselves and and I can understand
that I'm a member of allanon for quite a
few years we are not allowed to get
together and have meetings now I know
when I was a first time member if I
couldn't have been in that room with
those people holding their hands and
getting comfort for them I wouldn't not
have made it I probably would have taken
my own life things were really bad and I
needed those people to be around them
and be able to hold their hands and get
hugs that's what helped me to recover
myself from living with an
alcoholic um that's the thing I keep
thinking about all the kids that are
dying the people who are alcoholics who
do not get the help I I know of somebody
who very on in this uh early on in this
um took their own life they suffered
from depression and they were unable ble
to talk to someone in person they took
their own life this was a wonderful
wonderful human being that could not
deal with not having anybody to talk to
for for how long I I think the governor
has gone way too far beyond um it was uh
safety under color of law I remember
looking that up in the in the very very
beginning um and the censorship on
social media when you try to find
statistics about who's actually dying
you can't find it Facebook um was just
in Facebook jail for sharing about this
virus I don't believe that it's nearly
as dangerous as they say that it is um I
think that New Hampshire needs to stand
up and be an example so the rest of the
world can get back to normal perhaps a
different kind of normal because I feel
we've all learned something um during
this we've learned how to be kinded to
each other
um but the the kids are suffering kids
are are taking their own lives kids are
cutting themselves and and I'm not okay
with that as a former teacher 15 years
the thought about a child killing
themselves because they have no future
because of this overreach of our
governor I I think it needs to stop now
and I think we need to be an example for
the rest of the country almost 300
businesses last I knew had failed in New
Hampshire I lost my job as many other
people do because of the fear what we
need to tell people is that there is
nothing to fear so we can get back to
normal I'm afraid that if we just say
okay it's over without telling people
that it was greatly overinflated the
risk like you said you going to drive in
a car on the highway in a big city
what's your chance of getting killed
there I I think it's much greater than
the chance of being killed from um a
virus and I also concur with all the
other statements that I've heard I thank
you and I urge you to pass this and let
us get back with our lives again thank
you for your time thank you um are you
willing to take questions sure
unfortunately I see no questions um
thank you for your testimon thank you
for listening I appreciate
it
Daniel chair would recognize Donald
McFarland thank you uh my name is Donald
McFarland I am a member of the public
from orange New Hampshire uh and I'm
also an experienced professional in risk
management and Emergency Management and
was an EMT for about a decade while I
was living
elsewhere I had thought of making a
number of points today and many of them
if not all of them to some extent have
already been
covered um so I will appreciate if the
committee would just take note of a few
other points that I will throw in that I
think amplify some of what has already
been said
the resolution before
you although it does speak to facts that
are in evidence as well as uh clear
conclusions that that can be drawn with
really high uh
probability uh as to whether or not
covid constituted an emergency last year
constitutes an emergency now uh and
whether or not uh Mr sununu's orders
were appropriate or not the resolution
before you
nevertheless is not about that the
resolution is about whether or not we
should at this juncture be operating
under a
monarchy chrisen unu has chosen to
ignore the will of the people ignore the
will of the
legislature and continue to operate
unilaterally for an extraordinarily long
period of
time and I think when you look at the
the fact facts that are in
evidence uh from a personal standpoint I
was somewhat concerned in the very early
part of February uh when the first
reports of this virus and this disease
started to come in and I started to pay
significant attention to it in
mid-February and I think anyone else
that had been paying attention to what
was publicly available without even the
benefit of whatever additional
information may have been available to
the governor would have known by the
time if not of making his first
emergency declaration but certainly by
the time of making his first extension
to
it that what existed at the time was an
emergency that was not what it was
claimed that the numbers the statistics
the epidemiology did not bear out many
of the actions that were being taken
nevertheless he chose not not to bring
it to the attention of the legislature
to to make decisions but to make them
unilaterally and let's just hypothesize
for a second had this been a much worse
disease than it is uh and it clearly is
a real
disease had this been a worse disease
had this been everything that it was
hyped to be in in February and even into
the beginning of March of last
year the time for the general court to
come together and to agree on remote
working procedures to agree on how we
could continue to have a citizen
government in New Hampshire was then was
as early as possible before the disease
spread and we see that he chose not to
do that either so I think when we look
at the circumstance
today and we consider the facts that
have been set forth already by I think
I've agreed with almost every other
person testifying uh in the largest part
of their
testimony uh the the comment that you
just heard about mosqu being ineffectual
was something that even as late as May
or June of last year I hadn't had
occasion to do much research into and I
just assumed that they made a modest
difference although I was not frankly
concerned about it because my point of
view from the evidence that was clear uh
by then was that the spread was
predominantly feal oral and feal
junctive or not respiratory as the
primary mechanism nevertheless if you
did believe that respiratory was the
primary
mechanism when you do research as I then
did on the efficacy of
masks what you will find if you choose
to actually do the research and look at
the randomized clinical TR trials that
have been done and and the research
papers that have been published well
before
covid uh and and even as far back as 40
years
ago is that
masks may not even be uh a sop they they
may be counterproductive we can see with
a Spanish flu that people in some places
were being asked to wear masks for years
after the flu had
circulated and the incidence of various
bacterial diseases such as pneumonia
increased substantially we have a report
from the UK in 1981 a research paper and
a clinical trial a series of clinical
trials in fact
that was done by Dr Neil or that
demonstrated and I will quote from it
the conclusion is that the wearing of a
mask has very little relevance to the
well-being of patients undergoing
routine general surgery and it is a
standard practice that could be
abandoned that's in the surgical theater
never mind in the street or in your
local donut shop ladies and gentlemen I
put it to you that that the you the the
testimony you've re you've heard here
today has been unanimous and that is
quite remarkable but it demonstrates
quite how absurd the current situation
that we find ourselves in is and I ask
all of the committee to support and to
make clear the strength of their support
for house concurrent resolution to thank
you thank you for your testimony um are
you willing to take questions yes of
course
yet we have no questions um thank you
very much for your
testimony good luck with that file
behind I ne
ne anyo
Neo there's
someone willing to
accept the chair recognizes someone
named Neo
Neo
there we go I'm
muted are you
there going
once not
muted I think we move on
okay
Daniel
Richard
chair recognizes Daniel Richard you
would have to
unmute good morning ladies and gentlemen
how are you today fine thank you uh
welcome to legislative Administration
the floor is yours thank you let me be
brief and get to the points excellent
let's look at the scope of the delegated
powers the statutes themselves
separation of powers and non- delegation
Clauses of the Constitution of New
Hampshire prohibit the executive from
exercising the power of the legislature
a closer look at the EMP the Emergency
Management power statutes is warranted
to examine the language and the scope of
the EMP statutes in light of the public
health laws which has been ignored
throughout this crisis were were was
this panel aware that New Hampshire has
had a public health policy for 238
years I'll take that as a no uh we do
it's codified in title 10 New Hampshire
RSA
141c so let's look at at that and uh and
go from there um the emergencies New
Hampshire has been managing infectious
diseases for its entire history our
constitution mentions distemper in its
in article 43 of part two of our
constitution we survived small po fo
which was a ruthless killer that killed
at a rate of 30% we survived the Spanish
flu and many other provision provisions
of infectious disease and so including
this uh unfortunately the Spanish Flu
which was another ruthless killer and so
through hundreds of years New Hampshire
has codified its Public Health policy
for two major reasons number one public
health and Public Safety are two
different events
and they're different for this specific
reason a public health event is
different because of the cause of action
in other words how it how it causes the
injury and two the duration and scope
which tends to be a long running event
and this is why our Public Health policy
under 141 has a very has two critical
elements that have that New Hampshire
has been robbed of the governor has
taken this from the people by
invoking invoking emergency orders where
there was already Public Health policy
in place and it did two critical things
it provided the obligation of the state
to protect its citizens in other words
the the probable cause requirements of
the state to prove that there's a virus
in the first place and secondarily the
due process rights of its citizens so
under title 10 the public health
department is already charged the
director of of of our health Public
Health already has the ability to
quarantine people and to manage the
virus why why the governor went to the
went to the board excuse me went and
claimed to the court that he was going
to invoke the emergency statutes he
could have still invoked 445 and
declared an emergency and then invoked
141 as his authority but he didn't do
that the reason he invoked 447 is that
he was able to basically tell the the
court uh your honor your honor there's a
public potential Public Health crisis
coming our way but the public health
laws that have evolved over hundreds of
years they don't matter we're going to
throw them out and I'm just going to
make up new rules and new guidelines and
we've been living with them
since the next thing I'd like to say is
also that the original intention of the
emergency statutes Provisions were
Justified I'm not going to quibble over
the fact that no one knew when this
virus was first announced what the
damage and how it would spread and what
the consequences would be so stalling
temporarily for a few weeks to get
enough PPE in place to uh make sure that
our medical infrastructure was was uh
not going to collapse on itself was all
warranted that this was all legitimate
at the at the very first few weeks but
moving from there we now have the
following
consequences so uh let me let me make
this point the continued and unlimited
renewal of the Emergency Management
Powers called the EMP statutes have been
excuse me by the executive branch have
caused a constitutional crisis now
before this committee as such continued
renewal has been used to justify the
following State actions separate from
the stated purpose of emergency orders
the plain excuse me I I'm writing a
lawsuit here is now deprived of the
following constitutional rights and
continues to suffer irreparable harm and
here's what's going on now we're now
being deprived of due process of law
we're we've abolished all effective
means of redress of grievance we're
amending our constitution we're changing
our laws changing our voting laws
changing our form of government changes
to our representation at state and
federal level changes to our taxes all
these changes are being achieved without
the consent of the voters in direct
violation of the due process of laws
required by the Constitution required to
amend our
constitution so that that's really where
we're at now it it I believe that the
the concern of an emergency is long
passed and now we're causing more damage
than than can be justified thank thank
you for your
testimony uh would you be willing to
take questions yes
sir are there any questions from those
on
Zoom seeing none thank you very much for
your testimony thank you very much have
a blessed day you as
well um I see only one I put it
up
Mark Mark Mark from New
Hampshire
um Mark can you
unmute yes go um welcome to legislative
Administration can you give us your full
name please yes my name is Mark
Rosetti and I'm a citizen of the State
of New Hampshire I'm not a resident I'm
a citizen of the State of New Hampshire
my
testimony uh is first of all in favor of
passing
hcr2 my testimony is concerning the
closing of the general court or the
state house to be
for this to be seen we look at calendar
House calendar number 12 in a statement
made by the last speaker of the house
step shirtliff to close the general
court this was not lawful in his
statement he and the president of the
Senate Don ausi were historically I'm
quoting them suspending New Hampshire
legislative
activities he did not use
Article
19 from part two of our Constitution
which was to adjourn the house nor did
the governor use article
43 which was to progue the state so the
legislation and our house were closed
unlawfully this is uncons
unconscionable I almost finished here
secondly if we the public had our
constitutional redress of grievances
back and had a committee to do so it is
very likely that the closing of the
state would not have gone on for this
long we need to open the general court
for the people and for our legislators
to be
there and we need to do that Pronto we
need to re regard our government from
here forward as constitutionally sound
and in order to do that the voice of the
people must be recognized that can only
be done by by petition or remonstrance
as the general court was originally set
up and we need once again a redress of
grievance committee thank you for
allowing me to speak thank you for your
testimony um glad you are able to speak
uh would you be willing to take
questions if there are any most
certainly
I see none in the committee room any on
Zoom I see no hands raised thank you
very much for your testimony thank you
very much have a good day and I hope
that you'll think about the public and
pass HCI
to thank you uh last person testifying I
see representative Timothy haran has
raised his hands I would include
representative Aran to keep it short so
that uh we can stay on schedule and
still have somewhat of a
b okay thank you very much Mr chair so
I'm president Timothy Horan I represent
straford County district 6 which is the
town of Madbury home of your
distinguished uh ranking uh well home of
one of the members of your
representative wall and Durham which
actually did eventually get to host uh
several sessions of the legisl so I was
a member of the legislature last year
and I would certainly uh disagree with
the previous speaker a of
characterization of what speaker
shirtliff and Senator Susi were doing
they very much wanted the uh house and
send continue meeting it was not safe to
do so in rep Hall rep Hall was uh closed
the governor essentially locked us out
of the building and actually probably
terms of Public Health for good reasons
so took a while to figure out how to do
it um i Frank Frankly don't think that
uh governor cunu was perhaps terribly
help helpful to us or the members of his
party in the legislature but I mean
that's in the past we are where we are
now um it we did manage to meet UNH and
it was reasonbly successful actually
there were some members who uh guess
didn't meet the expectations of unh
behaved in ways that uh other people on
the UNH campus are not allowed to do um
but um I certainly we were caught off
guard with this nobody expected this but
um I state of emergency was very uh
absolutely Justified um I think uh I
think we still haven't processed just
how bad it is um like there's common you
know we've had at least half a million
dead but that's the biggest catastrophe
in US history but I think um we still
haven't quite process how bad it is
there's a lot of comment says I'm a
person in my 60s so I'm not that old but
I'm kind of older where they talk about
these death rates and so like
99.9% and you know 75 you know like like
in my age bracket it's
99.5% which I guess the idea is so
trivial we shouldn't be doing it now
that's one in 200 um I
I I would like to think I have more than
one to 200 chance of uh you know
surviving surviving through the next
next year or so so that's so
yeah um it's just very it's just very
serious and frightening thing and the
legislature had a hard time dealing
dealing with it but I don't think this
resolution is at all helpful and the
state of emergency it was absolutely was
justified do I support how senu went
about it um for the most part no on the
one hand I thought he was didn't inde I
agree with those who said he acted
unconstitutionally although I personally
think he probably should have been even
tougher and had even um more
restrictions um at least at least terms
of more not really restrictions but more
precautions should have been taken so
that and they should have been more
strictly enforced so I would uh I just
say this resolution is uh so I would
just advise you U vote against this uh
vote against this resolution so I don't
endorse houseu did it but or nor I
endorse everything he did but I think um
I think on balance the governor should
have that power and certainly it's not
fair to blame the legislature for the
fact that we um met only sporadically
last year um well one other thing I will
say is that we did attempt to pass a uh
committee on legislative continuity and
it never met but that was uh partially
was introduced a little bit late in the
process but I think um revenue shirtliff
and Senator Su made very much of a good
faith effort to keep the institutions
running and U Know un balance uh
unbalance um I was surprised by how well
we coped so um that's Bas my testimony
so thank you I have to take any
questions anybody wants to but I
definitely think this res resolution is
is totally it's just a very bad
resolution and it should be ited
unanimously in my opinion so have to
take any questions thank you uh seeing
No Hands raised I appreciate your
testimony uh with that I will close
there are no other hands we good to
go no that's
mark thank you for Testimony we're
closing the hearing on hcr2
and we will give us five minutes to
reconfigure everything and we will be
back at
10 put you on the spot um and I didn't
intend to asking about say who they if
they support well I pretty you were
right until all of a sudden I'm looking
at it oh when I come back I will tell on
the spot there were 288 supporting and
84 opposed wow but
nobody only Tim spoke in opposition so
oh wow I did not know that thank you Mr
chair glad I hopped on on Time thank I
still see Mr chairman would you like me
to the computer for the room for 10
minutes
maybe
some
we're a few minutes early
for the next Bills um but I wanted to
give the committee
rund down on the totals for the
last bill we heard
hdr2 um by my count there were
295 in support there were
85 in
opposition no people signed up as
neutrals down the
public I'm sorry that reps down the
public or yes okay yes in total anybody
have questions on that or does that
seem
clear and that's I what I did was take
the the number that is signed in prior
to our going coming on the air and then
adding in the people that uh raise their
hands
after ah so that's
hcr2
um M Mr chairman yes absolutely I I
didn't quite catch the numbers on the
support and oppos what was that again
295 to what
295 in support and 85 against Great
thank you
yeah and I think we have a couple
minutes before we open the hearing on
the next bill so I just wanted to let
anyone that is
on line and
listening to know that the calendar I
wrote this little blurb the plan is to
listen to the introduction of each of
the bills at the time stated in the
calendar each bill will have 15 minutes
of time to be introduced by the sponsors
and post sponsors at the end of that 15
minutes the hearing on that bill will be
continued until after lunch at
1:00 beginning at 1:00 members of the
public
will testify on any of the continued
bills they will be called upon and they
will state the particular bill they are
testifying about is expected that due to
the amount of people testifying we will
be limiting the testimony to as few as
two minutes per speaker I'm not sure if
that's true based on what I see already
on signing in I I'm not not sure that
there will be a limit um we will be
trying to get as many folks to give
their verbal testimony giving us their
verbal testimony as possible but I would
suggest that to everyone that written
testimony will always be accepted and
read by the committee members up until
midnight tonight and the address for
sending Written testimony's House
Legislative administration at
l.st do.
us chman at the beginning of each one
can you tell I don't know if the should
just us for
the that each so we have a sense I will
but before the hearing you want or as
soon as it closes just so we have a
sense of what weting yes sure thank
you so um I will open the hearing on
house build
277 and
recognize the prime sponsor and
proud thank you Mr chairman can you hear
me uh we can thank you for coming before
legislative
Administration I am Andrew Prout
representing Hillsboro County District
37 the towns of Hudson and
pelum the intent of this bill is to
ensure that the legislature is not
unable to utilize its power to declare
or terminate a state of emergency do the
inability to gather 400 members and meet
in a timely manner nor the chair's
unwillingness to do so the bill would
allow members of the legislature to file
a petition with the clerk of their
chamber in a like manner to the petition
authorized by RSA 16 to call for a
special session of the
legislature if initiated by the required
number in composition of members it
would be balloted by mail and assuming
that a majority of members responded
responded in the affirmative be the same
as a resolution passed pursuant to the
statutory authority of RSA 445 or 490
6-a these sections permit the
Declaration or termination of a state of
emergency or the termination of a
Judicial emergency order under a state
of
emergency while I do think that some of
the emergency planning that has been
done in the past has considered the
possibility that the legislature may be
unable to meet in saying that I'm
thinking both about RSA 445s lack of
limitation on renewals of states of
emergency and the Constitution's part
second article 5A related to enemy
attack I think the state of emergency we
are wrapping up just now was quite
different than contemplated by the
Crafters of those
sections there was no nuclear attack as
I think article 5A feared and no mass
destruction of the Civil infrastructure
as I think RSA 445
contemplated the male still works
a bit a bit slow in some places for
unrelated
reasons we have zoom fax machines and
scan PDF documents
now I also want to ensure the committee
is aware that several be bills are being
heard this morning in Edna that would
limit the executive authority to renew
states of emergency
indefinitely these bills would require
the legislature to act a continuous
state of
emergency this bill HB
277 would provide a process for the
legislature to act without assembling in
one place to meet the new Duty that
these bills would
impose I already mentioned RSA 16's
process for calling a special session as
an example of the legislature doing
business without meeting but I also want
to draw the committee's attention to the
Constitution part second article 49- a
which has a provision for the
legislature acting by and I quote
written request of at least one quarter
of the members end
quote we may not have any constitutional
Provisions for meeting over Zoom
but the Constitution does already
contemplate us acting remotely by
written request like in this
Bill thank you for your time
consideration I'd be happy to answer any
questions the committee may
have thank for your testimony
um you are submitting written testimony
I assume I I can I I can submit the same
I I uh just gave in written form as well
perfect um are there any questions by
the committee
any question up representative
Le uh thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative for taking the
question I just want to be sure I
understand the the the purpose or the
the goal of of HB 277 so it is simply
that um a following the standard
procedure for a petition if the petition
is then voted on uh remotely you know
via the mail or whatever balloted that
way and the petition is supported by a
majority of the chamber then it is to be
considered as equivalent to passage of a
resolution ending the in this case
probably ending a state of emergency is
that
correct that was correct it is uh would
apply to both declaring ending and also
the other section ending a Judicial
emergency order so any of the three
statutory ways to statutory triggers for
resolution okay thank you yeah I just
wanted to make sure I understood it
thank
you there any other
questions
seeing none uh thank you uh
representative do you know if there are
any other U co-sponsors that intend to
testify I have not heard from any of my
co-sponsors that they also want to
provide testimony
no I have not seen any on their list on
this list and I don't see
any hands
raised um sounds like you're free to go
not quite I'm up
next well uh you're going to have to
hang on while we
uh while we
reset seeing no other testimony I will
close the hearing
on
277 and will
reopen at
yeah 1120 for House Bill
280 um Mr chair the calendar says
11:15 right I'm looking
here and I'm looking at trying to give
our clerk a minute or two gotcha okay
thank
you
in the interim I will say that if anyone
signed on at 11:15 waiting to hear House
Bill
280 that the plan is for the prime
sponsors to introduce the bill and then
we will
continue the hearing um on that bill
until 1:00 when members of the public
will be allowed to
testify do
Haven all the same
top never done they just it may it's
hardest on the clerk right I mean she
doesn't know at that point when
someone's
testifying which Bill they're testifying
on so that's going to be the hardest
part that we try to do but otherwise
you're getting all of similar testimony
on the
same
top of bills
simar bill and the public speaks and
speaks then they say the same thing to
the next bill so this is better this way
because it's more efficient you get the
hearings and everyone gets to you know
if they have someone say we all speaking
on
HC speak such such saying similar things
it's even more complicated because Edna
is having similar bills as well so it's
um trying to just give a broad amount of
time that someone could raise their hand
and speak from one o00 on yeah and not
have an issue I think I may have
misspoke I think I closed I bill 277
when I should have
continued until one
o' just recess
yeah where's my where's my where's my
posy where's my back up here
I heard recess I heard
recess
one in In fairness Mr chairman uh
committee chairman get an enormous
amount of
leeway yeah we know what you're doing so
it's okay so so in in effect what um
what I need to do is open house bill 277
again and then continue it to one
o'clock
right yeah yeah you don't want to close
any of them right want to continue them
yep so as chair I'm opening House Bill
277 then
immediately um continuing the hearing on
until 1 o' this afternoon for anyone
that would like to T now I will open the
hearing on House Bill 28
which is relative to termination of an
emergency order issued by the governor
and recognize once again the prime
sponsor representative
Prout thank you Mr
chairman again for the record I am
Andrew Prout representing Hillsboro
County District 37 the towns of Hudson
and
pelum this bill would give the
legislature statutory authority to
determinate any specific emergency order
or any part of one by the resolution
process in RSA 4
45 current law allows only for the
termination of the entire state of
emergency and every emergency order
issued thereunder in an All or Nothing
fashion this bill would allow for a more
nuanced approach to address things the
legislature May disagree
with I'd like to draw the committee's
attention to RSA 490 colon 6A which
deals with judicial emergency orders
issued during a state of emergency under
that existing law the legislature
already has the ability to pass nuanced
per order concurrent resolutions
terminating judicial emergency
orders this bill would simply extend
that concept to Executive emergency
orders as
well thank you for your time
consideration I'd be happy to answer any
questions the committee may have thank
you representative uh I see no hands
raised uh you will submit written
testimony as well on that bill I will
and you are not aware of any other of
your co-sponsors specifying I don't see
any there
is I don't see a hand
rais so I will
continue House Bill 280 also until
1:00 does it provide the committee any
comfort to know how many people spoke in
or signed up and support or oppose as
yet does that make any sense happy to
give you the
information um on this bill
189 people signed in support
155 signed as opposed and one
neutral on the prior Bill House Bill 277
184 in support 65 oppos
no
6 yep
18465 oppos
Z anybody need that
again
no okay so we have two
continued and at
11:30 is that you again yes it
is the prime is in another committee so
asked me to introduce it on his
behalf um are you are you
testifying is representative lakas
testifying as well uh I believe he is uh
currently tied up in Edna committee
which is currently meeting hearing bills
and so he asked me to introduce the bill
on on his
behalf
okay um and also to give a little sneak
peek um our clerk house uh Paul Smith
would like to have a few minutes as
well so we have six
[Music]
minutes sent me a sent me an email that
he wanted to sign up and didn't make it
and but is asking for
couple of minutes to address his
favor I think the people at Zoom pick
the right today it's like a meat locker
in here
today 50
degrees tomorrow supposed to be real
[Music]
zero right
sum that give you an idea yeah do they
re the humidity that we
have it's huge so
must
[Music]
testim this Tes we access that where
does it go supposed to go to you you're
supposed to
get it goes through the email it's been
coming up on my pH all day so they have
been submitting it I've
seen
this is pretty good to that
yeah by the window
go for a
r
GPS keeping
up keep it on but
she
GPS
y
back on
time happy to
help
yes so here's one came in I don't
know
hcr2 that came in so you should have
received
that well you should rece this that WR
testimony just came
in
just you have
second
okay we're opening House Bill
325 which
[Music]
is uh relative determination of a state
of emergency by a simple resolution I
recognize FR sponsor no the one of the
sponsors represent
Pro thank you Mr chairman uh again for
the record I am Andrew Prout
representing Hillsboro County District
37 the towns of Hudson and pelum
standing in for the prime sponsor
representative Tony lickus who is
attending to his committee this
morning this bill would change the
authority to terminate a state terminate
states of emergency or judicial
emergency orders from a concurrent
resolution passed by both chambers of
the legislature to a simple resolution
passed by either
chamber The Authority for the
legislature to declare a state of emerc
Mercy would remain a concurrent
resolution part 2 Article 2 of our
constitution says the supreme
legislative power within this state
shall be vested in the Senate and House
of Representatives Each of which shall
have a negative on the
other in short it takes both chambers of
the legislature to agree to do
something conversely it should only take
one of the chambers saying
no to stop
something during the State of Emergency
the executive and judicial branches have
vast authority to act under RSA 445 and
490 col
6-a however we should not forget that
this Authority is not theirs it is the
legislator's authority that we have
delegated to them to manage the
emergency situation in a more realtime
manner than we customarily
operate the House and Senate should
still have a negative upon each other in
regards to this delegation of authority
and this bill would restore
that thank you for your time and
consideration I'd be happy to answer any
questions the committee may have thank
you representative
um any questions within the committee
room I'm seeing none any I do see a hand
raised representative
Smith thank you um you mentioned the the
two legislative Chambers uh having a
negative on each other I'm curious how
operating under this
legislation um one chamber could disent
from the other if what like if the
Senate decides that they want to end a
state of emergency and the house
disagrees um how do we exercise
that so uh there's I guess a couple
different aspects to what you just asked
um first the way I view the delegation
of state of emergency power that we have
in exist law is it's the legislature has
basically given its Advance approval
acknowledging that it can't act in a
timely manner during an emergency or a
timely enough Manner and therefore the
other branches of government may take
certain actions approved in advance um
you asked about how the house or one
chamber would descend from the other in
continuing state of emergency which
almost implies the authority to to
declare a state of emergency which would
under this remain a concurrent
resolution therefore require both
Chambers voting yes what this
legislation would do is say the
authority to end a state of emergency is
either chamber saying no and I would an
an analogize what this bill does to
withdrawing consent so either chamber of
the legislature withdrawing consent to a
state of emergency continuing would stop
it that if that answers your question it
does thank
you are there any other questions
from members on
Zoom seeing none thank you for your
testimony representative
um chair would like to call our house
clerk Paul
Smith his favorite
committee need to
unmute
Mr clerk would you like to
unmute you're making me look bad
CL no
he
Mr House clerk can you unmute hope
you're not
speaking the whole time
here I just sent the clerk a text
message to make sure he knows GNA read
mine too thank
you
you could jump
to representative Aron and then come
back I've been told by the clerk that
he's running to his desk as we
speak thank
you
from hook
or from the speaker's
office sorry members of the committee I
was uh in the speaker's office uh
talking about remonstrances my
apologies
um thank you uh Mr chairman members of
the committee for the record Paul Smith
Clerk of the house not testifying in
favor or opposed to the
legislation I just wanted to touch base
briefly um the house legal council and I
James Seany uh are planning to prepare a
memorandum for you as the committee on
this bill and uh some other issues there
are some concerns um with with how the
uh language is drafted and uh
specifically the powers of a simple
resolution which in fact has no force of
law um being used to determine something
of this sort of magnitude so I would
just uh I just wanted to sort of point
out that that the uh legal council and I
are uh working on drafting a memorandum
for you regarding this type of
legislation and um I just wanted to make
you aware of that so thank you Mr
chairman excellent you did that without
while catching your breath that was
remarkable um would you be willing to
take any questions from anyone here of
course are there any questions from the
[Music]
um we have a question of when we would
expect to see that memoranda so we're
we're working on that today we're hoping
uh to have something to you uh late
today tomorrow perhaps excellent thank
you and that'll that'll be email or will
that come through yeah we'll send that
via email Mr chairman okay thank you
very much um are there questions from
anyone on Zoom
or seeing
thank thank you very much thank
you um I see one other hand
raised uh representative
haran chair
recognizes the
representative up there is need to
unmute there I am on camera too I
apologize for not a tie I didn't know I
was going to be testifying on these
bills today but um this actually we're
not talking about the next bill but
applies as common applies to the next
bill like to it essentially gives um a
simple majority of one house uh the
ability to uh you know veto a state of
resolution to overrule the governor in
the other house and especially um right
now we have especially with this
especially obvious yeah are you are you
testifying on house go 325 yes I am yes
thank you I'm testifying against
Hospital 325 I continue to be resident
Timothy Oregon I still represent the
towns of Durham and Madbury and uh okay
I'm breaking my own rule I'm um this was
to introduce House Bill
325 we're going to continue this until
one o'clock and have other testimony
other than co-sponsors and sponsors oh
no I'm definitely not a sponsor and I'm
not I'm not in favor of it so okay can I
ask you to hold off until one and then
come back and raise your hand oh sure
why not yes thank you and you no problem
thanks sorry about that thanks no no I
it's it's a problem with the calendar
that uh it was incorrectly done by a
inexperienced
chairman so it's it's my my fault not
yours but one o'clock would be great for
you to testify on that and any of the
other bills at the same time oh that
would be good thank you yes so I'll i'y
be back at one and you're doing a good
job job so no worries
thanks thank you very much have a good
day no problem um with
that we
have five
minutes for House Bill 559 so I will
continue host Bill there is one other
person on there Don he had signed up
that he would like to
speak that is actually the that was
having his driveway Cloud
right so theoretically he should um he
should testify at one
o' okay um so I will continue the
hearing on House Bill 3:25 until
1:00 next up will be House Bill
um if anyone was interested on that one
post Bill 325 there are 106 people in
support 66
of 106
opposed but we have SIMPLE we have U
further information coming from
the there's actually no one signed up to
speak
on on
I don't know who that
is you see him on the
left I
have an honorable representative asking
zo hearing afternoon you
know other
than right off the
calendar
I don't type
well
back
there
don't see representative
poer we might ask representative assign
to
introduce the bill and then we'll
continue
it
y
you want me
to well you can just read the
title then we'll ask
question
legis as a courtesy to representative
poer we will introduce
the hearing the bill
for so I'll open the hearing on House
Bill
559 um and recognize not the prime
sponsor but representative assignment
for to introduce the Bill thank you Mr
chair I would like to just introduce
Bill 559 a bill that requires the
legislature to renew a state of
emergency beyond the initial 21 year
period uh looks like for the most part
this bill um just requires that uh the
state of emergency be extended by the
legislature itself after the 21 days of
Declaration um initially set forth by
the
governor thank you take you have written
testimony I would love to submit written
testimony to you I'll have to go write
it right
now thank you for doing that
representative um seeing no other hands
raised
yes there is
um and and lesle is not a co-sponsor so
she falls
into um this question that I have or
this um our our goal here Leslie if you
can listen to us is to uh continue this
hearing until one o'clock so that uh all
members of the public can testify on any
of the bills of a similar nature um so
we will be continuing the bill until
1:00 and if you would like to raise your
hand at that time we will recognize you
and take your
testimony no one else that I can see up
hand back
down thank you very much uh I will
continue House Bill 559 until
1: next up oh and if you want the
numbers on that one it is um in support
we have
164 opposed
17 no
neutral next up will be
at actually it should be at
right we were supposed to open that that
one at 11:45 yeah so we could actually
open up House Bill
389 if the clerk is
ready
um Mr Mr chairman
yes I think it shows 389 is opening at
three o'clock oh you're right you're
right you're right thank you so we've
done the four right
yes
sir right so we don't have to worry
about 389 great um I think we're good to
go we have nothing going until one
o'clock so you have an hour for lunch
and then we'll start with public hearing
at yes do we have any do you have any
sort of sense of how many people are
planning to testify I mean is it a lot
is it on on these four the only only
thing I have are the um are the sign-ins
and and so far there have been none my
my suspicion is my suspicion is that
um that when the other when Edna stops
their hearings that um there'll be a a
migration of people testifying on that
side because they're going into a work
session I think this afternoon and so so
it was kind of designed so that we could
then go to they would be able to testify
on any of these where they were
testifying on those in the morning I see
thank you does that sound Reon I mean I
don't have any way of knowing obviously
other than that so um it may be an early
afternoon and then we start right in at
3 o'clock on this bill U 389
and uh as I recall you had an issue you
need to be out by 4 right yeah I have to
teach at 4 so I need to leave before
4:00 that's all okay um I'm sure you'll
all
survive we do have Tim
so can back me up on any of these
things um good I guess we're free to go
until we're free to go until 1:00 um and
then we will start in right away with
testimony on all these four
simultaneously great thank you thank
you
if we'll see well what do you what do
you do if they say all of them Greg
because somebody's going to say that
um Tim Smith what are we going to do if
nobody signs up for speaking here
um well what's the the next order of
business I mean I I guess we take an
extended
recess so far we have one
hand I think um if I remember the
schedule right our next introduction was
at 3:00 yeah
yeah so then uh we'll we'll have an
uneventful recess till then
maybe
yeah play Virtual poker or
something
was just just following you Steve
Kevin in front of the earnings Zoom the
absolute standard in what this massive
video conferencing has
become all right I like it
Shannon
here
yeah all right so I would have thought
we would see some of the folks that were
on the HCR Bill pop
but
[Music]
thee how did you do it I just went to
sign in and I said hey is there any way
we can turn up the heat he said we'll
you and I'll send someone
up it is more comfortable it was like a
meat
Lo think
it windows open all
weekend like going the C house it's been
closed up all winter and you go in and
everything is the same
temperature we good
you good yeah the only hand I
seees representative caran I'm going to
have to uh promote you and give you two
hours or
less just popped out
here I
am representative are you there here I
am I put on the tie at lunchtime so I I
uh I certainly don't plan to use the
full two hours I have better things to
do with the two hours than uh listen to
my self talk and you probably feel even
more so that way so I continue to be
representative Timothy Oregon I
represent straford County District Six
the towns of Durham and Madbury so I'd
like to uh speak in opposition to the uh
bills that we heard uh bills of this
committee heard heard this morning like
uh all three or four of them I've lost
track of how many there are can you um
can you limit for the clerk for the
purpose of the clerk making notes here
can you late your comments by by
Bill sure oh that's that's doable let me
uh P up the uh agenda here to see which
was which okay
uh
I've got print outs of some of them
so so the first 277 then we went to 280
okay well 277
um problem with 277 is I think this was
one of the ones that uh allowed
um 27 with 277 I guess is one of the
ones allow just one branch of the
legislature to terminate the state of E
emergency and that's unwise because uh
that effectively gives 13 Senators a
veto over the Govern the policy to
terminate the state of emergency and
that's a problem with some of the others
um especi well the spend and especially
the small bodies with thetically it's 13
the same could happen in the uh same
could happen in the house especially if
we do it during the current emergency
where we still really haven't figured
out how to meet we had what I I think we
all agree is a pretty chaotic two days
session last year so there's no
guarantee that uh that who shows up so
there's definitely a possibility you
could have a group that's large enough
that more than the 200 needed for a quum
but still like not really like represent
a cross-section of the of the house
showing up to terminate a state of
emergency that might actually still have
uh might actually still have broad
support
um and that's uh also a problem with 325
so that's big flaw with big flaw with
IG fall with both of those see um in
hoopersville the last one which nobody
all came to speak and that requires a
concurrent resolution that's a little
bit more problematic but even then and
of course that want to also the state of
emergency expires after 21 days which is
an unreasonably short time um even when
there isn't a pandemic even when people
aren't scared for their lives you know
even when every aspect of our life
hasn't been turned upside down so
especially now those are all um un
realistic expectations and I
U also like to go ahead and uh once
again defend I think the leadership of
the last uh legislature they've been
kind of
uh they've been kind of given rather
shabby treatment in retrospect you know
they've been accused of just walking
away from their job and nothing can be
farther from the truth so I I know for a
fact that they both worked very very
hard to keep the institution going um
with and frankly with no help from the
governor's office at all as far as I
could tell I'm sure there's more going
I'm not privy to a lot of what was going
on just but what I could see is a
veteran member um who's fairly involved
in the legisl who at least uh tries to
stay involved in the legislative process
I saw very little support coming from
the uh from the governor so it was
mostly uh the uh the majority leadership
especially of the house trying to keep
things going and they uh they did keep
things going but it took a it was a
struggle and we're still not back up to
capacity so uh I uh I I think all all
three of these are bad it's very
dangerous uh it's very dangerous to give
one house of the one chamber of the
legislature the chance to over you know
terminate a state of emergency uh
for for not necessarily any good reason
at all the state of emergency that we're
all still living under we've been living
under for almost a year I don't
necessarily agree with everything of it
I certainly don't disagree with I
certainly don't agree with every aspect
of how the governor handled it but I
think um I think the precautions if
anything were have not been strict
enough so even though um it's also worth
noting that you know the great mass of
the people the people who don't pay any
attention to what we're doing here in
conquer or Bedford or wherever it is
we're located at the moment um most of
them they're they seem to be
appropriately uh they seem to be you
know appropriately scared by what's
going on they see they're taking you
know appropriate precautions to go to a
uh like for example you go in any store
people are staying six feet apart they
are messed up they are even fing the
little green arrows on the floor of the
Market Basket so for the most part the
uh you know the people are taking this
very seriously so the people who we
serve I think they almost seem to
understand it more than those of us in
the legislature do to a certain extent
so I I I so I think uh so I think uh
this is not I think this is not a good
idea to uh you know make it too easy to
terminate a state of emergency I me I
could imagine certainly a governor could
could abuse it and
think there's we don't need to pass
these bills we still have also plenty of
other tools in Arsenal in case some
future Governor to totally abuses it but
I don't think that's the situation to
here and I certainly speak of someone
who's not at all a fan of Governor cunu
so I definitely U you know I I'm not a
big fan of how he's been handling things
but I do think uh I do think the state
of emergency was was appropriate and um
and uh I Al once again I'd like and I I
do think uh I think these bills are a
bad idea so I'd be happy to take any
questions uh thank you for your
testimony I will ask if there are any
questions in the committee room for
representative
par Mr represent par you said all three
of these are B does that mean you're not
speaking on the other two that you
spoken for everything or what oh well
I'm not sure exactly how to do we're
hearing all three so I'm I'm not opposed
to passing uh any of those bills that we
heard this morning so I don't know uh
like I'm not sure exactly how to go
about saying it but we're having a joint
hearing on the four
bills so all four you are you are
registering opposition yes exactly guess
that's hopefully that's an adequate
answer thank
you um any further questions any
questions from anyone on Zoom or by
telephone seeing none
thank you representative oh thank you
thank you Mr chair so thank you you're
doing a doing a good job under difficult
circumstances and uh try not to freeze
to death in the meat locker so
thanks thank you repres um I see no
other hands um and no one has signed up
here we've still not heard from
representative
Hopper
um Prime sponsor of
559 me I think his own committee is
meeting today so that could be where he
is but I don't I'm just
speculating he's in criminal justice now
right yes are they meeting
today I don't
know they are they are
meeting
anybody for not have ability to testify
I think you know what we normally do if
the prime sponsor doesn't show
up
understand um but
also we got two hours until the next
bill I don't think that would be bad do
you know where does it say what
room represent Mr chairman I believe it
they're in 206
208 thank
you representative Hill yes um I'm
sending Gary a text right
now okay we're sending representative
assignment we'll see what you get there
for okay either way
thanks that being a case
um he had see the see Les on wasn't that
weying
to never
answered
spoke okay that wasn't the that tet yeah
yeah that was that's the
okay someone we had before that we were
that never came
on
ne
yeah we had two signed up
speak what about
does anyone know how the attendance was
in Edna for questions this
morning no
idea
well give it a
minute
representative
otherwise
you um and Tim wanted to know if he
should be here right at
three
too bad we could almost
ex heard the that
we's we
have so who would have thought all
people saying
how upset everyone was or
is
yes yep okay uh thank
you up criminal justice is in exec
session so representative representative
Hill yes I just got a word back from
Gary Hopper he wants to know when he has
to come to 301 and 302 and I said
now yes except
we're 306 we're
30638 oh
sorry let me write that
down we just heard
representative R out that they are doing
ex
session no they were in the middle of
taking a vote so should I go I mean
they're right below us
no
represent sent him a taxt he said he can
be there in 10 minutes is that too late
nope that's fine we'll wait for okay
I'll tell them 10 minutes we'll wait
okay we're recess for 10 minutes that'll
make it
125 wait till
125 got
[Music]
it okay I just send them the
note
your
for
59 okay thank
you there a c it right there
it's
okay so we are back uh in session on
House Bill 559 we now have the prime
sponsor blessing us with his presence
and test testifying um representative
paper would you like to talk to us about
your bill
559 thank you Mr chair thank you
Representatives um for the record I'm
representative Gary Harper representing
Hillsboro count uh District 2 which
includes wear and Dearing um I brought
this bill uh
forward in part because of my
constituents I had people all during
this this epidemic calling me and saying
what are you doing why why aren't you
people legislators doing anything about
the
um what a lot of people see are very
oppressive Decisions by the governor I
think uh um executive order
76 where
he um ignored State Statute and created
a database for people getting
vaccinated which went against
uh um article 2B of the State
Constitution which is a right to privacy
which we we voted in by an 80% majority
just District in
2018 and he ignored rsas which say
people can opt out of being in a vaccine
um registry so he he basically discarded
the law and ignored the Constitution and
there was another uh executive orders my
uh voters had problems with and it
seems not necessarily now but if you if
you look around the country and look at
California where the the uh governor of
California is creating uh Draconian
executive orders then having a dinner at
a fancy restaurant with dozens of his
rich friends without masks on so telling
the people of California you have to do
this and he does whatever he
wants um it seems to me that that type
of behavior could easily happen in New
Hampshire the way executive
orders are in place
now so House Bill uh whatever my number
is
um 559 five that's a good number
559 is intended so that if we have a
governor that oversteps his bounds we
the
legislature have the ultimate say on
whether to to uh continue or discontinue
so in this case when he signs an
executive order in a certain amount of
days the legislature would have to
convene and vote to continue or not
continue through through a concurrent
resolution and if there is no vote of
the legislature then the executive or
order dies
a a timely death that's basically it so
the legislature that because you we all
know our voters we all know that they
you know they feel comfortable talking
to us in the
supermarket and if they're really
upset we should have a an opportunity to
chime in on executive orders and if the
governor believes that an executive
order is absolutely necessary then he
should be able to convince us as
legislators that that's the case so that
when our uh a constituent comes up to me
says why aren't you doing acts I can say
well the we had a discussion with with
about that in the legislature and the
government made this compelling argument
and so we're extending it for another 28
days so that's the intent is just so
that um the people still have a say in
government even during an executive
order because right now I know uh
constituents who have called the
governor tried to talk to the governor
and they get zero response so I think
this um allows them to people of New
Hampshire more
say in these uh very difficult times
because I think one of the the um some
of the Fallout of
covid-19 is the
um people's inability to have control
they feel like they've lost control of
their government and that's not an
acceptable condition in a to Live Free
or Die State I'll give I'll give you a
simple example when the governor signed
the I believe it was the first executive
order that um had churches all shut down
one of the consequences of that was that
every 12-step meeting in the state shut
down you had an ENT you in in a crisis
situation we have
now it is very very difficult for people
who are struggling with addiction and so
when the one form of support that isn't
government supported it's all volunteer
that that entire swap of help that was
out there was killed instantly because
all of almost all of those 12 step and
uh uh uh 12-step type meetings AA na ha
all of those meetings or almost all of
those meetings take place in churches
and they were all killed all at once the
number of people relapsing we talk about
about the the number of people dying
from covid I don't know what the number
of people dying from overdose right now
but it's really high I also know that
the number of people relapsing and and
um having you know suicide and
everything else has gone through the
roof
so by Intro by passing this law where
the legislators can hear from their
communities come in and um support or
reject a uh an emergency order
I think will give um make the governor
more account the governor more
accountable to the people and the people
more uh us more accountable to the
people also which is kind of the point
of um what we do for work really I think
that's it thank you for your testim that
was that an hour and
15 minutes um has uh you have any time
for questions sure
anyone in the committee have
questions anyone on Zoom have questions
I have
one um you stated in your testimony that
uh that people are
feeling like they're not being heard or
they have no opportunity for for being
heard um we have five bills here on
Solutions all the dealing with emergency
Powers
um in total of the five we have
four people
testifying
um either four or against total of four
so so does that not apply the the idea
that people want to have their voices
heard or are they requesting for you to
be their
voice um no I I uh thank you Mr chairman
but I don't believe that is particularly
relevant in in criminal justice we get a
lot of testimony we had a bill a few
minutes ago where 400 people chimed in
not they didn't talk but they right but
that's because those are well publicized
bills there's advocacy
groups um that uh Jin up support or Jin
up
people to fight back against a bill ab
and C in a little while we got a
marijuana bill I know there's a lot of
people who want to speak on
that how straight they will be when they
speak is another question but anyway
there's a lot of advocacy groups for for
different things that we hear up here in
the legislature I don't think there's um
the same kind of infrastructure for
bills such as this that
um um to talk about uh
um emergency orders and things like that
it's kind of a new phenomenon so there's
not I don't believe there's that kind of
support to notify people things and I
certainly
didn't uh did not do a good job telling
anybody about this so it's partially my
fault
I as a followup these all have indicated
support for um somewhere close to 200
people have have signed on to
support um these five bills yeah but yet
only four wanted to
testify if
Shan yeah I I don't know I have a heart
um I it was just asking for your
impression or or your idea of whether
you think that there is a low minority
or whether you think that um your bill
is necessary because there are so many
people wanted you to represent them in
this
action
um I'm not sure it's
relevant if if the you know it's like uh
in a and the Declaration of Independence
says we hold these truths to be
self-evident I think that the need for
this is
self-evident the idea that
um
uh that we could end up with a governor
like Nome who could just keep hammering
us with executive orders and the
legislature has no
recourse to uh to put a put a put the
breakes on I think it's self-evident
that we need to do something
all we have to do is look around the
country today and we know we need to do
something now if the E executive orders
are legitimate and there's ample uh
reason to uh maintain them or to to uh
resubmit them then the legisl
legislature will vote to support it
anyway so it doesn't do any harm it only
um um allows the people to have more of
a voice in what's going on in their own
State because right now under an
executive order like I said the governor
specifically has ignored
law basically you know just wiped it out
which I'm not sure that's the place for
an executive order and and if he had to
come to the legislature and say and and
we ask why are you doing this why is
this necessary at least he would have a
you know some sort of justification for
it so I I think this is self evident I
don't think I need five million people
calling in support but primarily I think
people are intimidated by you Mr
chairman
that
um thank you
repres there any other bill that you
would like to
testify I don't
know thanks very much um seeing no other
hand oh no we do have two other hands um
thank you for your testimony am I all
good you're all good thank you sir thank
you
folks come back to the legislative
Administration
any chair will
recognize um lesle
is that
right Lesly your hand is
raised can you promote de
Johnson there she
go
Leslie unmuted yeah Leslie are you
there oh muted
again sorry about that there you go all
right thank you I I just wanted to
quickly ask the gentleman's name that
just spoke I didn't catch it and I
wanted to write it down yes
representative Gary Hopper h o p
r Gary Hopper okay and I just wanted to
say real quickly um thank you for giving
me a voice and for giving people a voice
because uh what he said is true a lot of
us have felt like nobody is hearing what
what we say and I really want to
appreciate all the time you're taking
and to thank represent representative
Hopper uh for mentioning um AA and also
alanan because like I said I'm a member
and it's been really hard for me not to
be able to meet with those people um at
this time when everything being so
difficult that's that's all I want to
say thank you very much for giving
people a voice I certainly appreciate it
excellent um it it your last name is
again Tetro right yeah Tetro it's French
Canadian that's why it's pronounced uh
different than it looks
T just making sure that you the same
person we talked about yes yes yes I am
and thank you I really appreciate this
very much it makes me feel hopeful for
the first time in a year so thank you ah
excellent thank you um
chair will recognize de
Johnson de Johnson are you
there you'll have to
un unmute Deb
Johnson hello yes hello and welcome hi
appreciate you having these meetings um
uh the only reason I'm speaking right
now I don't have anything prepared but I
hear you saying that you don't see
anybody showing up for this I only found
out about it this morning um I I I will
try to stay calm but my outrage at
what's happening I don't recognize my
state I don't recognize my country I
don't see Freedom we are not a nanny
government we do not need you or the
governor or anyone else to tell us what
to do but for God's sakes at least go by
the way the government is supposed to be
run it is not supposed to be John sonunu
making all of the decisions we have a
state legislature for a reason I I I'm
sorry that I I sound upset but I really
am upset I I I my anger every day grows
so much more I can't believe what people
are allowing to happen to our businesses
to people in nursing homes dying alone I
cannot believe this it has to stop life
is never been safe there's always been
danger we do not need to be bubble
wrapped and I'm sorry that's all I'm GNA
say right now but because I I'm afraid
of what I'll say so I'm GNA sign out now
thank
you uh thank
you
anyone
else oh we do
GL Mr C
start we'll have to
unmute chair recognizes BL conto thank
you than you Mr chair Mr chair uh first
I want to I want to remind people that
you guys are are not not necessarily the
chair but all the representatives who we
see today you represent the people of
the Granite State the people who voted
you into office are the people who you
need to be um I don't know if I want to
say loyal to but uh you don't you don't
go and do your own thing you you
represent the people of the Granite
State the the Live Free or Die state by
the way I'd also like to remind
representative Timothy Horgan we can see
your face um this whole time so I want
to control your emotions there when when
something said that you don't agree with
oh well then I'll shut off the video
thank you there that solves that problem
yes sir it does hey but anyway um
uh I just really wanted to say the same
kind kind of thing just that that you
represent us and in the last caller who
expressed their um their feelings there
that is the vast majority of the people
that I speak to and see around that's
what they're thinking they're thinking
what is our legislative doing what is
the governor doing this is supposed to
be the Live Free or Die State and we
just see these things and we're we're a
year into this thing now and we
understand more and more about the virus
about how it works how it doesn't work
and a lot of people just feel that our
constitutional rights in in the granite
state are just being trampled upon and
they really want their voices to be
heard um so that's really all I'd like
to say today and thank you for having
the the committee here and and hearing
our voices appreciate that thank you Mr
K uh would you like to take questions um
I guess I don't know who may ask me a
question but by all means that's part of
the the game Gary no one knows where the
questions are coming from are there any
questions from anyone in the
committee how about anyone on Zoom or
telephone I have one um so
uh it sounds to me from your testimony
that um
that you believe
um the general feeling within the
populace is that
uh they're upset or angry or and and
want us to do something do I have that
right your last phrase was they want to
do what sir they want us to do
something um no actually I feel that the
the lady before the last person said we
can self-govern ourselves you know if if
we go to the store and
someone po before this pandemic and
someone was coughing or sick we would
steer away from those people just like
our grandmothers used to tell us if
someone has a running issue or they're
coughing stay away from those people we
know how to to protect ourselves and
it's not that we want you to do
something we want you to do the right
thing which is not to trample on our
constitutional rights on our state
rights that's really what we're we're
after we're just we're we're kind of
appalled we're like what are these
people doing and then it's day after day
after day it seemed at the beginning
there was just more mandates More
Everything happening and we're like when
is this going to stop and now that we I
don't want to say we fully know about
covid but uh we have a greater
understanding now these things need to
be um we need to open our state back up
we really do we need to follow the
example of Ronda santis in Florida and
just do what he do he does I'm I'm I
like uh Governor sonunu I really do I
obviously voted for him um I believed in
a lot of what he's doing but then when
this happened it's like what who is he
getting counsel from who who is who is
uh having him think these would be good
measures to take and we're we're just
all sort of Blown Away scratching our
head saying we live in the Live Free or
Die State and we can't go to the store
or go to church or or if we do we have
to stay six feet away from people and
it's it's it's really odd it really is
we'd like it to be all reversed and just
go back to the way it
was I think we all agree on that um
thank you very much thank you for your
testimony thank you Mr
chair I see no
others all
right close the hearing
hearings um so I'll be closing the
hearing on host
559 and we have only one left on PO Bill
389 to be heard at
3:00
there there here's fine if you're okay
with here so I'm as soon as I'm done
booking right back back over to County
to help them ex
bills um so
we're up and running is that
right can't anybody for them to nod
their head that they can hear me we're
good we can hear you yeah you're all set
great uh so it being uh three o'clock
I'll open the hearing
on HB 389 and recognize the prime
sponsor
langa Lang thank you Mr chair thank you
commit members for taking my testimony
I'm representative Tim Lang I uh
represent the towns of Tilton and S hton
bellnap 4 um presenting before you House
Bill 389 House Bill 389 is a response to
the uh state of emergency I understand
you've been listening about that all day
long so I won't go into to the details
of RSA 445 so I'm sure you're probably
more conversent at this point than I am
um what this bill seeks to do is uh
create a little check and balance uh as
we saw in this latest state of emergency
um the legislature played almost zero
role in what happened with the state of
emergency and this is the first time the
state of emergency law has been put into
effect and basically I'm you know we're
doing a Lessons Learned here uh one of
the things we learned is that the
legislature should be involved in these
processes and have a little bit of
oversight over what's going on in the
governor's office um to that end I
created this bill and what this bill
does is it creates a legislative
emergency uh executive orders oversight
committee at the beginning of each term
10 members of the house or 10 members of
the legislature four from the Senate six
from the the house would be appointed to
a a committee that committee will if in
the case of a state of emergency uh the
committee's responsibility is to review
the governor's and approve the renewal
of emergency orders so we recognize that
the governor needs to be able to manage
the process especially when things are
moving fast so the first 21 days he gets
a pass um he gets to be able to write
his executive order and and and have and
take action but after the 21 days the or
or before that expire is if he wants to
renew that order he must bring it before
the the uh legislative emergency uh
oversight committee executive order
oversight committee um and the committee
will review the order and decide whether
or not it should move forward or not in
the case of a TI Vote or a majority vote
it would uh move forward the the the
order would stay in place in the case of
a a vote to override or veto if you will
the governor's emergency order that
would be in place the governor would be
able to reissue the emergency order if
it substantially changes so the order
would have to be could be on the same
subject matter would have to be a little
bit different um or if he wants to bring
the same order back 10 days after it
expires for whatever reason he can go
back again in front of the committee and
asks to renew that um that executive
order again um there's a second half of
this uh law after the uh creation of the
uh committee and this was in response to
some when I originally was floating this
idea we had a working group as as I'm
sure you heard working on a bunch of
these bills and there was some concern
about just having 10 members a super
committee if you will without that what
happens if the house or the Senate don't
agree with what they did and so if you
look on page two starting at line six
going all the way through line 30 that
was my attempt to create a check and
balance against the committee um however
I I you might have gotten an email from
representative proud that talked about
some constitutional issues and I think
he's right um and I think that he that
this these sections espe especially
starting with number one and going
through number five um are not
appropriate they probably do violate the
constitution or at least an
interpretation of the Constitution
however I think letter C is still an
accurate measure and what letter C says
is that under um chapter 16 which is how
we call a house in the session if if a
members wanted to call a house in a
session you get 50 uh representatives
and eight Senators to sign a petition
and submit that um that process could
still apply and what this would allow to
do is extend it to allow us to have um
the same veto Powers as the house on
those same executive orders so I do
think letter C is appropriate um however
numbers one two three four and five are
probably unconstitutional I'd be happy
to work with the committee to draft an
amendment to strike those um I I again
it was my attempt to try to work um and
create a check and balance against the
committee um and I think letter C on its
own using chapter 16 does that
um again the rest the rest of the bill
is relev to process and procedure just
talking about emergency executive orders
as compared to regular executive orders
to make sure it's clear that we're
talking about any order issued as a uh
as relative to the uh underlying
emergency order uh declaration is what
we're talking about and I'm happy to
take any questions I know there's a
whole lot of information really
fast thank you uh representative you
will take questions to say
and go ahead thank you Mr chairman you
have the effective date January 1
2023 that's two years away how why did
you decide on that thing so again the
reason was we wanted to make sure we
didn't impinge upon it I think that
everyone is of the opinion will probably
be out of this existing emergency order
by that date and I didn't want the run
the risk of bumping up against this
current executive order uh or state of
emergency being in play and and we now
have conflicting law we got to deal with
that so my idea was push it out far
enough that by no way shape and form can
we impact this state of emergency and
the idea is to fix the law going forward
as I said this the first time we
implement it we kind of have a couple
Lessons Learned on this situation thank
you very
much uh any other questions inside
committee inside the committee room any
question yeah representative L uh thank
you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question
and I really apologize I came in late uh
because I'm at work um what are the
sections you said you think are
unconstitutional or you would probably
delete well so if you look at uh page
two of the bill starting
at so page two of the bill starting um
section uh 3 C line 11 line L all the
way down to line 30 I think kind ofes is
what chapter 16 says and talks about uh
compensation to the legislature which is
in this which is in the Constitution and
I try to rewrite it here to include that
but I think there's a possibility it
could be deemed uh unconstitutional so
I'd rather strike it and have a nice
clean bill and then if we decide we want
to approach that I'm happy to look at
that next session next term or next
session um and see if maybe we can put
that check and balance in but I do think
it muddies the water and I think it
should be
struck
follow sorry thank you I appreciate you
just going back over it for me I I had
missed that very I came in at the tail
end there so than thank you that helps
thank
you any any other questions from the
committee or from Zoom y thank
you um so you're willing to bring an
amendment to the committee I'll be happy
to get the amendment drafted I'll reach
out though well last get it all done you
guys have enough work to do as a chair
fishing game I'm all done my bills so I
got plenty of time on my hands
[Laughter]
we didn't we didn't need to hear
that any uh any other questions from
anyone on Zoom or by phone you see no
hands
raised anywhere think you're good to go
represent thank you back over thank you
thank
[Music]
you I don't see
any
there are any members of the public that
would like
to shim in um now it's the time to raise
a hand and let us
know give it
a few seconds to see if anybody's
looking for
that
yes um representative wall thank you m
chairman again my only concern with the
effective date is technically we're not
supposed to commit a future legislature
to any like this so right that'll come
up in in executive session I think
[Music]
um we're getting a nodding of the head
from representative le as well so and
actually representative Smith's picture
is nodding I think
it is
indeed so with that being said we don't
I don't see any other
questions who
is oh uh yes so Claire representative R
thank you you know this question
probably should have been for the
sponsor um on page two of the bill um
line three uh it states that a majority
or a tie vote shall be required to renew
the order and I thought I heard Tim say
well the the sponsor of the bill say
that if it's TI vote then it gets
extended um I I am concerned where you
have a committee with an equal number
and it would seem to me that you would
want to have an unequal number so there
is never a situation of a tie vote so
either approve it or you don't and um
that's all I had is that a question for
the sponsor you it would have been it
would have been had I got my hand up
quick
enough to answer it still here so you
still great great thank you Mr chair
thank you representative rard for the uh
for the question so um this was a
struggle when I was when I was writing
this bill about having an even number
the idea behind is an equal number of of
the majority party and the largest
minority party um that the T the the uh
membership is broken up to and I guess
what I came down to was the idea being
that if you were going to override the
governor's executive order you better be
able to convince at least one member of
the other side that is the right thing
to do and if you can't then we should
renew the order um that it has to be
such an egregious order that people
agree even across party lines otherwise
it's just a it could be used for
political purposes is you know if you
have a republican majority and a and a
Democratic governor the Republican
majority just ride all over the
Democratic governor and erase every one
of the every one of the emergency orders
um just out of spite um and so or the
inverse and so I was trying to avoid
that my way of doing that was to make an
equal number and to say that a tie goes
to the governor and um otherwise you
have to have a majority vote to veto out
an executive order follow up
absolutely the the then my next question
would be um if there is not a majority
vote then why would there be a renewal
shouldn't there be uh a no it is not
going to be
renewed yeah I think it's the inverse of
the question but yes I could see it I
could see it written that way as well I
guess my point was if it's anything
other than a majority or a tie it's
going to be um veto
it's a majority if you vote a majority I
know it's a little bit ugly worded but
um and again I'm happy to bring an
amendment in if you can come up with
better language or I want me to revisit
that and just say on a majority
vote
um to veto to Governor's executive order
I don't know how you want to word that
but I I could look at that it was kind
of an ugly phrasing trying to get to it
okay
you representative Le
thank you Mr chairman and just a comment
on that I think the um it really depends
on what the question would be how the
question would be put to this committee
so for example if the question were uh
you know shall the state of Emergen or
the emergency order whatever it is uh be
ended um then a TI vote would mean it
continues because the motion would be
defeated by a Tha vote so if I so it
really depends on how you want to set it
up in terms of what should be brought to
this committee that would sort of
determine how you want to go with that
that's all it's just a point so again so
this doesn't talk about the end of the
State of Emergency the end of state of
emergency still only has two processes
the government the emergency we do the
special session and we do a a joint
resolution or a concurrent resolution so
this is relative only to the emergency
orders themselves so the motion would be
shall we renew emergency order number
blah blah blah and the answer is yes or
no and depending what the majority is or
shall we veto either one doesn't really
matter I guess it's the idea is that you
have to have at least a majority to
renew it or TI vote to renew it um if
you have less than that then you
wouldn't R do
it that make sense my backwards well
again it depending on the motion a TI
vote could have different results
correct um depends on what the motion is
okay because again a TI vote defeats the
motion um so it depends on what the
motion is that's all I think we're agre
the motion is if the motion is to renew
a TI vote defeats the the renewal but if
the motion is to end the emergency order
then a TI vote allows the order to
continue okay I'll be happy again to
address that yeah you just may want to
clarify on that that's all right sorry I
think we're agreed uh there's another
hand raised by representative
Smith yep thanks um is your
looking for the right way to phrase this
would would you imagine that if if this
passed um there probably need to be uh
an accompany an
accompanying um change to the house
rules to to lay out some of the
procedure for this um or or would you
expect the the statute to kind of stand
alone so I'm not sure we would need
rules uh again you know the idea behind
is if the governor is not going to if
he's going to let the executive order
die then he's he's not he's not going to
bring it before the committee for a
renewal the thing the governor is going
to be bringing for the committee is a
renewal you know I want to renew
executive order number two um I mean
emergency executive order number two um
and then the vote would be shall we
renew it or not um it's not I guess
that's where I get a little bogged down
I don't know why that would require
Amendment amending the rules because
we're not ending the state of emergency
that's still in statute that's
completely different this is just
oversight on the governor's emergency
executive
orders follow
up um not not a question I'm I'm just
sort of
um the way that I I think when when I
see something like this I'm just
thinking about the what the procedure
would look like on the floor in order to
get that question in front of the
committee um but I I suppose that's
something we can try and figure out
later so again if I may again the idea
is that it would is a standalone
committee that would be uh would would
meet once a state of emergency was
enacted once the governor signed and
invoked RSA
445 um then this committee would be
constituted and then once he starts
issuing emergency orders any emergency
order he wants to renew he has to bring
before the body to get approval
basically do I understand that this
committee would be set up at the begin
beginning of the legislative session
rather than waiting for the emergency
order be taken correct I'm a big
believer to time to plan for emergencies
before the emergency so the idea is to
establish the committee at the beginning
of each term have 10 members assigned
and then if a state of emergency is
declared you already know who's
responsible for the
committee thank
you any other hands up
anywhere
I think we're up another hand represent
L thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking the question just and again I
think I know the answer to this but the
only thing that can come before this
committee would be um the governor
requesting to renew or continue an
emergency order is that correct that's
correct okay so the committee itself
followup um the committee itself could
not for example say okay we think the
order should be renewed the governor
disagrees but we're going to override
the governor on that I'm sorry can you
rephrase that question on not sure I
followed you oh sure um if the governor
doesn't want to renew an order could the
committee override him
no about the renewal of the emergency
order so the governor would have to
bring it before the committee thank you
thank
you sounds good I think
we're done with questions that I can see
I don't see any hands I don't
see great um thank you again thank you
guys representa thank
you uh with
that with that I will close the hearing
on
um unless there is anything else that I
can think of we have one more session
scheduled for next Tuesday so anyway uh
38 9's closed I'll tell you the numbers
here uh support
168 oppose
14 no
neutral and no one else
testifying um so we have a uh from for
the committee purposes uh in organizing
uh your schedules it looks like Tuesday
I've not yet heard back from the chief
of staff whether that's Tuesday was to
meeting
time uh I
agree um and that's why I sent out the
message early saying does anybody have a
problem with
this so um I don't see it in the
calendar no it's it's not but that is
the day that they gave us um and again
we're up against the the March 11th
deadline here on the good news um the
only thing we have to do on that day
is um that one bill that was my
oversight from last time that one
hearing 186 yeah um which should be
quick I mean I don't see does anyone in
the committee have a reason to think
that that is in a quick um hearing and
and vote um it seems to me it would be a
a 15 to 20 minute
I can't say it's going to be longer than
that it's a bill we've already had we've
already approved it unanimously I think
I think we were fine um that being the
case beyond that the only other thing we
have is the is the executive sessions on
the bills we heard today so um that's
what would be in front of us if you need
to do it by Zoom that's fine we just
need to see the whs of your eyes
so um that's the only thing I the only
rep that I think had a problem with
Tuesdays was Brett Richards um and I'm
doing my best to get an answer for her
whether it's morning or afternoon I
don't have a preference the committee
have a
preference yes
represent uh probably morning I'm only
thinking that um I may have exec also in
the education committee at the same day
um but I don't know when you know
nothing's been scheduled yet so I I
don't know hopefully maybe he can ask
chairman lad tomorrow what his thinking
is okay um because we have hearings to
do there yet too so yeah well I think
that's why we were given the day that
you know it was the choice of Tuesday or
Tuesday so but I'm not sure if it's the
question of Tuesday morning or Tuesday
afternoon I think we just have Tuesday
at this point and and we can decide
amongst ourselves okay so a
preference we
ac well just that one
bill we're hearing that one bill and
acting that one bill
back what we today yes and then we're
done for the 11 oh yeah um I would from
morning
earliest morning early do I hear
anything other than
that no I I agree I mean I'm in
Manchester so it doesn't affect me but
if anyone's got a town meeting to go to
um you know we can probably oblige them
if we finish up by midafternoon I don't
I it's more voting day than to meeting
right is it I thought it was just voting
day um
yes um I wish You' see why I wish it was
in the morning morning so it sounds like
morning is the consensus if that's what
we can push for and would that be excuse
me Mr chair this is would that be a 9:00
am start
again um that's Up For Debate as well I
don't I don't care that would be my
preference as early as possible would be
helpful yeah all right that would be
fine
I've never known what to do between 9
and 10:00 anyway and that's so I'm just
as happy to make it nine o'clock
this I'm up from 5:30 anyway course so
um so let's for right now unless um I
tell you something different um we'll
say nine o'clock on Tuesday that's what
we go in the calendar it didn't go in
last week because because it's a Tuesday
we have the requisite four four days if
I goose it to this calendar so that's
why I was hoping back before in order to
get it in on on
Wednesday um good then then we'll be
wrapped up I have not heard or seen a
single bill that will be coming our way
for the next half um if that's any
consolation that's not to say they won't
find something else for us to do but um
that's what I'm seeing so
far and that's all I have in front of me
right now um any other questions anyone
has okay all good thanks guys see you
next
week thank you thank you thank you